Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Gianni Infantino, seines Zeichens FIFA-Präsident, findet die WM in Russland ganz, ganz dufte und hat das natürlich auch genauso kommen sehen. Wir wollen diese Aussage einem Realitätscheck unterziehen und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost. Ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich hier in einem Tribünengespräch mit zwei Menschen auf die WM zu blicken, die auch vor Ort waren und die uns ein bisschen andere Perspektiven bringen können und wo wir das dann eben mal abgleichen. Mit deren Sicht auf diese Weltmeisterschaft. Deswegen begrüße ich bei mir zum einen mit seinem Rasenfunk-Debüt Nils Arnold et Grummelgru auf Twitter. Er war als Fan vor Ort bei der Weltmeisterschaft. Servus, Nils. Und außerdem mit dabei, Hendrik Buchheister et ha-Buchheister auf Twitter. Freier Sportjournalist, lebt eigentlich in UK und war jetzt vier Wochen lang in Russland. Hallo, Hendrik. Ich freue mich auch gleich mit euch noch mal einen etwas anderen Blick auf diese Weltmeisterschaft zu werfen. Schließt so ein Turnier immer ganz schön ab. Bevor wir damit loslegen, möchte ich aber schnell noch ein paar Menschen danken. Nämlich zum einen Achim, Moritz, Hendrik. Das ist nicht der Hendrik, der hier zugeschaltet ist. Julia und Julius. Sie sind alle Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wegen läuten wir euch. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Wer uns etwas unterstützen möchte, erfährt alles, was er dazu wissen muss. Auf rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Das soll es aber genug der Vorrede gewesen sein. Jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, Nils, erzähl uns doch mal kurz. Wie warst du denn jetzt bei der Weltmeisterschaft? Wie lange warst du da? Wie viele Spiele hast du gesehen? Fass mal kurz zusammen, bevor wir dann ins Detail gehen.
Okay, ganz grob gesagt, mein Ziel bestand davor, hört sich jetzt hochtrappend an, dass ich alle zwölf Stadien sehe. Und danach habe ich auch meine Tour geplant. Und so waren es ungefähr, ich glaube, es waren 15, 16 Tage. Und also nur die Vorrunde, da kann man die Stadien besser abklappern. Das war eine Premiere für mich, denn bei den letzten Trainieren habe ich auch meistens das ganze Trainier begleitet. Aber trotzdem kann man in den 16 Tagen schon einige sehen.
Und du hast in den 16 Tagen wirklich alle zwölf Stadien geschafft, denn die lagen ja ultraweit auseinander.
Genau, also das war vielleicht schon eine Herausforderung, habe ich beim Planen dann auch gemerkt. Das habe ich dann auch bei, wo ich angekommen bin, andere Leute getroffen, die das Gleiche vorhaben, hatten, war schon so, dass sie auch davon gesprochen haben, ist nicht so einfach, wenn man die ganze WM mitnimmt, kein Problem. Aber wenn man sagt zwei Wochen, dann ist das eher sportlich. Ist auch deswegen sportlich, weil ich natürlich, mein Aufhänger waren die deutschen Spiele und dann darum planen.
Gott sei Dank kannst du dich auf die Gruppenphase konzentrieren jetzt.
Ja, haben danach auch alle gesagt, vollkommen korrekt. Aber davon mache ich es eh nicht abhängig. Dafür mag ich den Fußball zu sehr oder die Länder kennenzulernen. Deswegen passt es so. Aber es gehört auch mich dazu, das Organisieren der Reise macht auch Spaß. Und deswegen alles gut gegangen.
Und Hendrik, du warst jetzt auch die kompletten vier Wochen vor Ort. Wo hast du dich denn die meiste Zeit rumgetrieben?
Genau, ich war tatsächlich die ganze Zeit da, den ganzen Monat. Bin jetzt auch noch da. Ich bin in Moskau gerade noch bis am Mittwoch. Ich habe mich rumgetrieben in der Vorrunde, die größte Zeit in Yekaterinburg, also ganz im Osten dieses Austragungs-Korridors. Und habe mich dann eigentlich in diesen vier Wochen so nach Westen vorgearbeitet. Also ich war dann bei ein paar Spielen in Nizhniynov gerottet, ich war bei Spielen in Kazan und dann jetzt zu den Halbfinals und den Finals in St. Petersburg und Moskau.
Das ist immer noch schwer vorstellbar, wo ich jetzt mit vielen Leuten schon gesprochen habe, die drüben in Russland waren, während dieser Weltmeisterschaft. Aber obwohl man all das übers Fernsehen mitbekommen hat, ist es doch einfach nochmal eine lustige Vorstellung, wenn man dann in Google Maps die sich die Orte nochmal anguckt und dann erstmal merkt, wie weit entfernt das von den Sphären ist, die man so selbst vielleicht mal als Tourist oder sonst wie irgendwie besucht hat. Nils, was mich bei dir interessieren würde, bist du denn Ground-Hover oder woher kommt das, dass du so eine Wahnsinns-Tour auf dich nimmst? Du hast gesagt, du magst den Fußball.
Klar, also ich liebe den Fußball, sonst wäre ich nicht hier, so wie ihr beiden auch, denke ich. Ich würde mich aber nicht als Ground-Hover bezeichnen, dafür mache ich das viel zu wenig intensiv. Also ich kenne die Leute aus der Szene, sage ich jetzt fast schon, aber ich würde mich nicht so betrachten. Ich sehe unglaublich viele Fußballspiele im Jahr, aber die schon meistens in der Umgebung, wo ich lebe, wo ich mich aufhalte. Bei den Turnieren habe ich halt einfach den, ich weiß, der Anspruch hört sich schlimmer an, aber wenn ich das Land kennenlerne, will ich möglichst viel vom Land sehen, dann reise ich viel und dann sage ich auch, okay, alle Stadien. Und das ist meistens kein Problem. So gehe ich das an und dann klappt es auch meistens.
Das hört sich so an, als hättest du das schon häufiger gemacht bei Welt- und Europameisterschaften.
Genau, genau. Deswegen ist es auch interessant, dass du da ansprichst, dass die Entfernungen so groß sind. Ich meine, in Brasilien waren sie genauso groß und da war es noch schwieriger zu reisen, denn in Brasilien kam man ja gar nicht mit Zug in Amazonas-Gebiet und so. Deswegen war das noch eine größere Herausforderung. Dafür war es halt ehrlich gesagt nur zwei Wochen Zeit, sonst war ich auch die ganze WM oder EM immer unterwegs. Aber mit ein bisschen Planung und Flexibilität geht es eigentlich. Und wie gesagt, für mich gehört es auch dazu, das Ganze. Also das Land zu sehen und auch mit den Bahnen zu reisen, das macht das Besondere für mich auch aus. Ich nütze einfach einen Tagesflieger vom DFB-Fanclub und fliege zu einem Spiel hin, voll betreut und wieder zurück. Also davon bin ich weit entfernt und auch die Leute, die ich kenne. Also nur als Beispiel.
Ein Mensch, der hättest du Oliver Pocher kennenlernen können.
Also ich muss auch zugeben, mir liegt es wirklich sehr viel daran, auch das Land kennenzulernen. Das ist wirklich keine Phrase. Und ich gebe mich auch wirklich nicht als Fan zu bekennen. Ich meine, das weiß Hendrik auch, dass alle mit diesen Fan-IDs rumgerannt und so was. Ich habe die Dinge wirklich nur angezogen, wenn ich ins Stadion rein bin und sonst weggelegt. Also ich wollte nicht so als Fußball-Tourist auftreten, sondern klar die Stadion angucken und die Spiele sehen, aber ansonsten auch was vom Land sehen und vor allem nicht nur dort landen, wo auch die Touristen landen und die Fans landen, muss ich zugeben.
Klappt das dann auch?
Prinzipiell klappt es schon. Ich hatte diesmal viel weniger Zeit. Also vor zwei Jahren war ich auch in Frankreich unterwegs. Das ist Europa, das ist einfacher, aber da war so viel Zeit, da ist man auch sehr weit weg. Und Frankreich ist auch jetzt nicht so das Fußballland. Passieren war das noch einfacher, da war man komplett raus. Ansonsten, das kann auch Hendrik bestätigen, es ist alles ganz toll geregelt gewesen von Zügen und U-Bahnen und was auch alles. Aber ich habe auch gerne mal dann irgendwann zum Beispiel noch ein Trittligaspiel in Moskau angeguckt, weil ich dachte, ich kann nicht weggehen, ohne Fußball noch in Moskau gesehen zu haben. Und allein da hinzukommen, in so einem Vorort von Moskau, war schon eine größere Herausforderung, aber das war halt da wirklich das wirkliche. Und dann sieht man auch, dass es schon ein Riesenunterschied ist, von dem, was man im Fernsehfleisch sieht und die Berichte liest und was Russland und Putin geschaffen haben für die Fans. Und das, wie das wirkliche Leben ist. Und einen Tag dort draußen, das war schon das wirkliche Russland. Das war dann auch wieder sehr interessant.
Das hatte ich mir tatsächlich auch vorgenommen, mal so ein Amateurspiel mir anzuschauen. Und ich hatte auch zwischendurch mal, ich glaube, das war in Nizhny Novgorod, so zwei, drei Tage, wo nichts war und wo ich dachte, das würde sich jetzt optimal passen. War dann aber leider nichts los zu der Zeit. Also ich habe es dann zum Keilspiel geschafft. Hätte es aber auch mal spannend gefunden, jetzt genau wie du sagst, eben mal diese andere Fußballwelt und die wahrscheinlich viel ächtere Fußballwelt Russlands zu sehen, als diese FIFA-Welt. Und weil du es angesprochen hast, was die Organisation und dieses Reisen und so angeht, das war auch meine Erfahrung. Also ich war jetzt in Brasilien nicht. Russland war meine erste WM, von daher kann ich es mit Brasilien nicht vergleichen, aber es war hier schon so an jedem Bahnhof, von dem man angekommen ist, standen direkt die Volunteers, die einem gezeigt haben, wo es zur U-Bahn geht. An jeder U-Bahn war ausgeschildert, wo es zum Stadion geht. Also das war top geregelt. Ich bin relativ oft mit diesen, die sind in Russland sehr beliebt, mit so Nachtzügen unterwegs gewesen. Die brauchen dann so von Yekaterinburg nach Kazan 15 Stunden und die fahren nicht besonders schnell. Also ich dachte, man ist zwischendurch, da kann man mit dem Fahrrad nebenher, da ist man wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel langsamer. Aber man steigt da halt abends ein und kommt am nächsten Morgen an und ist ja so einigermaßen ausgeschlafen. Und diese Züge waren, ich glaube, ich habe das 3-4 Mal gemacht während der WM, die waren ausnahmslos pünktlich, also beziehungsweise die kamen dann immer so 3-4 Minuten vor der angekündigten Einkommenszeit an und ich überlegte mir so, das ist ja Wahnsinn, der erste Zug ist 15 Stunden unterwegs und kommt dann 5 Minuten zu früh. Also das war schon, das hat mich echt erstaunt und ich glaube, mir war das auch so, die WM hat auch vorher durchgeplant, ich habe mir so umgroben überlegt, zu welchen Spielen ich möchte und wie ich das dann mache und habe auch schon mal geguckt, dass ich mir die Reisen so gut wie möglich vorbuche und das ist dann schon ein Unterschied zwischen dem, was man sich so an seinem Schreibtisch zusammen sucht über booking.com und irgendwelche russischen Bahnwebsites und aber wenn man dann da wirklich vor Ort ist und sieht, hoffentlich funktioniert das alles so, aber es hat tatsächlich irgendwie alles so funktioniert. So und das liegt tatsächlich auch daran, dass das zumindest während der WM, ich kann natürlich nicht sagen wie es sonst ist, aber während der WM, dieser Ablauf, was zu öffentlichen Transportern ging, das war schon echt top.
Ist das denn teuer da mit diesen 15 Stunden Zügen in Russland zu kutschieren?
Ist nicht so wahnsinnig teuer, weil sonst wären die möglicherweise auch schneller. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht der wahnsinnig große Komfort, also man muss schon, wenn man ein Problem damit hat, mit fremden Leuten auf engem Raum Zeit zu verbringen, dann sind diese Züge nichts für einen. Für mich ist das kein großes Problem und ich finde sowas auch spannend zu erleben, so weit es für mich auch so zum Teil zu so einer WM-Reise dann doch dazugehört. So die Abenteuer dort mitzunehmen, von daher hatte ich damit kein Problem und die Züge kosten dann so zwischen 40, 50 Euro und dafür kommst du dann halt von einer Großstadt in die nächste und das find ich dann schon okay. Es gab während der WM auch von der FIFA organisiert, so ich weiß nicht, Nils, ob du damit Erfahrungen gemacht hast, diese Fan-Züge, da konntest du dich vor dem Turnier für anmelden, konntest du Plätze buchen, mit denen konntest du dann glaube ich sogar umsonst fahren. Das habe ich aber wiederum nicht gemacht.
Genau, das habe ich auch nicht gemacht, Entschuldigung, wenn ich dazwischen quetsche. Ich habe auch diese Züge benutzt, die du beschrieben hast. Ich habe es, muss ich zugeben, ich habe sogar gefreut auf die Züge, ich kannte die auch schon von der Ukraine von vor sechs Jahren. Ich habe auch so Züge benutzt in Indien. Also ich finde die cool, weil es auch das wirklich, da reisen die Einheimischen, das finde ich interessant. Bei diesen Fan-Zügen war es so, da hat man natürlich vorher das Ticket haben müssen und ich habe nur für drei Spiele Tickets gehabt und deswegen konnte ich die gar nicht nutzen. Aber sonst, die Züge haben extrem viele Leute genutzt, auch um solche Orte, die sind oft wieder am Abend von diesen kleinen Orten, neher von, Entschuldigung, den Spielorten in der Nähe von Moskau, wo man zurückfahren konnte, in vier, fünf Stunden sind die wieder zurückgefahren nach Moskau. Das haben viele Leute einfach genutzt, um von Saransk zum Beispiel nach Moskau wieder zu kommen. Sprich, die sind wirklich nur fürs Spiel hingefahren nach Saransk und haben dann gleich diesen FIFA-Zug wieder zurückgenommen. Aber sie waren auch komplett ausgebucht, die Züge.
Genau, ich glaube, diese FIFA-Züge haben dir halt nur was gebracht, wenn du wirklich von oder nach Moskau wieder musstest oder von Moskau weg musstest. Also ich war jetzt, wie gesagt, in der Vorrunde die meiste Zeit im Osten und da fuhren diese Züge, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Aber dann sieht man natürlich sehr wenig vom Land. Aber wenn du das jetzt gerade schon ansprichst, Nils, du bist also losgefahren auf diese Reise mit nur drei Tickets zu spielen im Gepäck. Wie schwierig war es, Tickets vor Ort zu bekommen? Wie macht man das dann? Wie funktioniert das auch mit der Personalisierung?
Also ich muss auch sagen, für mich gehört es auch dazu zum Turnier, mir die Tickets vor Ort zu organisieren. Denn ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich günstiger wegkomme und zudem habe ich auch, ich habe keine Lust, ich habe dazu sagen, ich habe das ganze Turnier, ich habe die letzten Buchungen gemacht, was ich mir Züge gebucht habe, einen Tag bevor ich losgeflogen bin. Also ich war extrem spät dran. Mich stört es aber nicht, ich mag das spontaner lieber. Mit den Tickets ist es so, natürlich, das kann auch Händige erzählen, es geht darum, diese Fan-ID zu bekommen, was auch gleichzeitig das Visum war. Ohne Fan-ID kein Ticket, ohne Ticket kein Fan-ID, man kann es drehen und wenden, wie man will, was ja auch erklärt war, warum zum Beispiel die Stadion teilweise so leer waren in der K.o.-Runde. Auf Deutsch, ich habe mir halt, bei der Fan-Club Nationalmannschaft, muss leider sagen, den unzöglichen, da ich aber aus pragmatischen Gründen drinne bin, um Tickets zu bekommen, bekomme ich die Tickets auch immer, da ich da schon sehr lange drinne bin und ich habe da auch gar keine Gedanken drüber machen können, habe mir die drei vorrunden Tickets für Deutschland-Spiele organisiert, habe die bekommen, Fan-ID und damit hatte ich das Visum und dann habe ich gesagt, den Rest hole ich mir einfach vor den Stadien. Ich selbst hatte keine, ich war vorhin nicht in Russland, ich wusste nicht, wie es da läuft von den Stadien, ich kenne es von anderen Ländern her, meistens kein Problem. Was interessant war, dass der Schwarzmarkt fast nicht existent war. Das kenne ich ganz anders, von Europa, von Brasilien kenne ich es ganz anders. Schwer zu sagen, warum, ich denke einfach mal, dass die Leute auch nicht wussten, zum Beispiel hat die Fan-ID nichts damit zu tun, welcher Name auf dem Ticket gedruckt ist. Du kannst Fan-ID in den Scanner reinschieben beim Eingangsstadion, danach das Ticket wird nicht geprüft, ob es übereinstimmt. Dann sind wahrscheinlich weniger Schwarzwerkennende unterwegs gewesen, auch ein Grund, also musste ich gucken, dass ich mir Tickets organisiere und meistens halt auch dann wirklich von Russischen Einheimischen, das war dann auch meistens mein Ziel und es ging dann auch immer irgendwie, war aber auch viel mehr von Glück abhängig, also ich, sonst kann ich von anderen Ländern her hingehen, ein bisschen gucken, beobachten und dann einen günstigen Ticket kaufen. Hier war das mit viel mehr Aufwand versehen, aber es ging auch rückblickend ganz gut.
Wie lief das denn, wenn ich da einmal zwischensfrage darf, mit dieser Fan-ID, wie lange im Voraus hattest du die? Ich hab das von Leuten gehört, vor allem von Leuten aus England, die dann recht kurzfristig noch nach Russland wollten, weil England dann wieder erwartend halt recht weit gekommen ist und die alle gesagt haben, jetzt wollen wir da aber auch hin, die dann während des Turniers noch diese Fan-ID sich besorgt haben und das wohl relativ unkompliziert noch ging. Wie war das denn bei dir?
Finde ich interessant, also das war bei mir schon ein Monat davor, also ich habe mich da karten-für-die-für bekommen Anfang des Jahres, glaube ich, und dann habe ich auch gleich die Fan-ID beantragt und dann konnten sich auch Zeit lassen. Ich habe eben deswegen nicht darauf geachtet, weil ich gewusst habe, das klappt sicher und hat auch geklappt. Und wenn du das gerade erzählst, finde ich es interessant, denn ich habe auch Berichte gehört von Leuten, die eben selbst spontan hinwollten und da war das Zeitfenster dann zu klein. Aber ich glaube, also, ja, das Problem ist auch, man sollte wissen, diese Fan-ID ist durch das Visum, also es hat uns Fans sehr leicht einzureißen, weil sonst ist Russland nicht immer so einfach, mit mehr Aufwand verbunden reinzukommen. Andererseits hat man natürlich auch komplett den ganzen Datensatz abgeben an den russischen Staat, was ich ja nicht so toll finde, aber da war ich dann wohl auch sehr pragmatisch, um da reinzukommen und zu den Spielen zu kommen.
Da gab es ja auch die Berichte, dass Gesichtserkennung an vielen öffentlichen Plätzen und auch im Umfeld von Stadien eingesetzt worden sei und da sind dann eben logischerweise auch nicht nur russische, sondern auch Bürger anderer Staaten mitgescannt worden von diesen Kameras. Hat man davon eigentlich vor Ort was gemerkt? Also wie würdest du, Nils, die Sicherheitslage oder die Vorkehrung, die Präsenz von Sicherheitskräften vor Ort beschreiben?
Ich würde gerne noch kurz einen Satz davor sagen, als ich gesagt habe zu meinen Freunden, dass ich nach Russland reise, haben viele gesagt, oh Russland. Also das sieht man schon allein, das Image oder das Bild von Russland ist leider schon sehr negativ. Man kann halt so stehen, wie man will, das ist schon mal eine Vorgeschichte. Der andere Punkt war, dass mir von vornherein klar war, dass der russische Staat, sprich Herr Putin, alles dafür tun will, dass er das Land gut präsentieren wird, dass alles funktionieren wird und dass dementsprechend auch die Sicherheitskräfte das Ganze in Schach halten werden, was auch immer passieren könnte. Also auch diese Idee, dass da dann die Hooligans auftreten konnten, hatte ich erstens keine Angst davor und zweitens habe ich auch das nicht wirklich erwartet und genau so hat es sich auch gezeigt. Ich kann ein gutes Beispiel nennen. Wenn man aus dem Stadion rauslief und zurück zu Ubern wollte, ewig weite Wege, ist eine Geschichte, hat man vielleicht in Frankreich einfach ein paar Polizisten hingestellt und dann Band gesperrt. In Russland standen einfach in einer Reihe dann nicht fünf Polizisten, sondern bis zum Stadion einfach mal 200 Polizisten und haben die Leute rausgeleitet. Also die Sicherheitskräfte waren enorm präsent, nicht aufdringlich, aber sie waren präsent. Gleichzeitig waren aber auch sehr viele Volontiers, was Hendrik schon angesprochen hatte, unterwegs und dann wollten einen helfen. Also das Personal war Wahnsinn. Also egal, ob du angekommen bist, im Stadion war das Personal nie das Problem, hat man das Gefühl gehabt. Zum Sicherheitsgefühl, da ich eh kein Typ bin, der sich unsicher fühlt, kann ich dazu nicht viel sagen. Und die Plätze, wo die Touristen bereist haben, da wurde so viel gemacht, damit sie sich wohlfühlen. Ob das jetzt sehr sinnige Kontrollen waren, sprich überall Scanner oder Röntgengeräte zum Durchleuchten von Gepäck, die einfach nur so aufgestellt wurden und dann man durchlief und gar nicht wirklich geguckt wurde. Also eher Placebo-Effekte oder so was, keine Ahnung. Aber da wurde sehr viel zumindest gezeigt, dass man sich dran gedacht hat. Ob das wirklich sinnvoll war, weiß ich nicht. Aber es hat den Effekt gehabt, glaube ich, dass die Leute sich schon sehr sicher gefühlt haben, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten.
Hendrik, wie war es denn bei euch Journalisten?
Ich finde es interessant, dass du sagst, dass du die Sicherheitskräfte, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, sehr präsent empfandest. Weil ich fand das nämlich eigentlich gar nicht so. Also man hat schon viel Polizei gesehen. Die waren aber zumindest, das was ich gesehen habe, nie behelmt. Also das hat dann schon mal nicht so diesen extrem aggressiven Touch gehabt, den es zum Beispiel in Deutschland bei Fußballspielen manchmal hat. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass man dort eigentlich versucht hat sehr zurückhaltend zu agieren. Eben natürlich möglicherweise immer unter dieser Prämisse, dass natürlich Russland ein gutes Bild abgeben möchte und dass man nicht den Eindruck eines Polizeis oder Hochsicherheitsstaates da erwecken möchte. Aber ich fand es, wenn ich das vergleiche mit meinen Erfahrungen bei der EM vor zwei Jahren, wo ich war, von den Olympischen Spielen in Rio, da fand ich die Sicherheitskräfte sehr viel präsenter und die wirkten auch alle sehr viel hektischer. Und in Russland fand ich, war es so sehr zurückhaltend, aber effizient. Also ich habe eigentlich nur einmal gesehen, dass es so einen Anflug von Stress gab. Das war nach dem Halbfinale in Sankt Petersburg, wo dann die Leute zu der U-Bahn-Station gegangen sind und da sind dann zwei, drei Jungs, die offensichtlich angetrunken waren, haben entweder untereinander Stress gehabt oder auch mit der Polizei sich angelegt. Und da war dann die Polizei da und hat diese Lage sehr entschlossen aufgelöst, würde ich mal sagen. Aber auch nicht so, dass man davon wahnsinnig viel mitbekommen hätte, sondern es lief so sehr effizient ab und aber wenn es jetzt darum geht, wie das bei den Journalisten war, also man ist zum Stadion gekommen, da gab es einen Medieneingang, da musste man dann durch so eine Sicherheitsschleuse, durch so ein Drehkreuz, musste vor seiner Akkreditierung scannen, also was für die Fans die Fan-ID ist, für die Journalisten die Akkreditierung, dann wurde, ich glaube, der erste, der erste Sicherheitsmann, der da entstand, guckte einem in die Augen, ob man es auch wirklich ist, also ob man auch wirklich derjenige ist, dessen Bild auf dieser Akkreditierung gesehen ist, dann musste man seine Tasche durchleuchten, Also so ein Röntgen-Geräte, das man am Flughafen kennt. Was sicher aber auch, also was jetzt aber nicht Russland-spezifisch ist, das gab's in Frankreich auch und es gab's in Rio auch. Und dann, also es hat schon sehr was von Flughafen. Es ging aber tatsächlich alles relativ zügig und die Leute waren freundlich und dann war es manchmal so, dass sie noch deinen Computer sehen wollten, den sie dann im Rucksack irgendwie entdeckt hatten. Und manchmal musstest du ihn auch anschalten und musst dein Handy einmal anschalten. Und dann wurde man dann noch abgetastet und da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass die Securities da am Anfang sehr motiviert waren und sehr genau abgetastet haben und dann am Ende hat dann, war meine Eindruck, die hat die Abtastdisziplin dann so ein bisschen nachgelassen und da war dann so, ja, okay. Aber natürlich nur bis dann zum Finale, also Finale war dann schon wieder, da haben sie schon wieder sehr drauf geachtet, also logischerweise. Genau, und dann war man durch diese Sicherheitsschleuse durch und dann war man halt so in diesem Bereich, der für Presse zugänglich war. Da gab es dann halt das Medienzentrum und dann konnte man ins Stadion. Und wenn man dann vom Medienzentrum ins Stadion ging, da gab es dann auch, da musste man sein Ticket nochmal vorzeigen, wenn man in die entsprechenden Bereiche wollte, aber da gab es dann keine weiteren Kontrollen mehr.
War das dann aufwendig, eine Akkreditierung für die Weltmeisterschaft zu bekommen, Hendrik?
Also ich hatte damit keine Probleme und ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht von anderen Kollegen, die Probleme hatten. Also es ist so, dass man, ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube ein halbes Jahr vorher oder so seine Unterlagen einreicht oder sich bewirkt erst mal beim DFB, der über das deutsche Kontingent dann verfügt, also die verschiedenen Teilnehmer, die verschiedenen FIFA-Staaten haben Kontingent für Journalisten und dann sagt der DFB, der DFB checkt einen dann mal kurz oder manchenweise kennt einen DFB auch und dann war es glaube ich so, dass von DFB so ein Link kam, um sich dann bei der FIFA zu akkreditieren und da muss man dann auch alles vorlegen, was man wahrscheinlich auch für diese Fan-ID braucht, also Perso, Reisepass und persönliche Angaben und so weiter und dann hat es irgendwie ein, zwei Monate gedauert und dann kam die Bestätigung. Also von daher ist das glaube ich einfach das normale Prozedere, wenn man sich für so einen Großturnier akkreditiert, aber ich habe jetzt wie gesagt von keinem Kollegen gehört, der Probleme bei der Akkreditierung hatte.
Ja, das ist ja gut. Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, ich hänge noch ein bisschen an den Tickets, Nils. Also ich finde es ja interessant, dass man die vor Ort dann einfach so kriegt. Ich bewundere dich auch, dass du diesen Thrill mitmachst, dass du sagst, ach, ich kaufe die auch lieber vor Ort, dann ist es günstiger. Erst mal magst du uns sagen, was heißt denn günstiger? Mit welchen Preisen muss man bei WM-Spielen rechnen?
Also gut, das bekomme ich auch immer dann vor Ort raus, denn man weiß ja nie, wie es wirklich ist. Ich gehe eigentlich immer mit der Prämisse rein, ich zahle nicht mehr als was auf dem Ticket drauf steht. Das ist das Erste. Nach den ersten zwei Spielen bekommt man schnell raus, was wirklich gezahlt oder gewollt wird. Und da habe ich jetzt bei der WM gemerkt, ich habe eigentlich also maximal immer die Hälfte gezahlt. Ach, manchmal vielleicht ein Drittel und einmal habe ich mir auch ein Eins geschenkt. Also ich gehe nicht darum, dass ich hier keine Geheimnisse erzählen will, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach die Erfahrung. Ich mache das schon seit so vielen Jahren und ich kriege immer wieder Tickets geschenkt. Da muss ich gucken, dass mich nicht an die Schwarzbankhändler kommen, sondern an die Einheimischen. Es ist einfach eine Frage, ob man da auch ängstlich ist. Ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass wohl einige Leute, die dann mit den Tickets rumliefen, Neet-Tickets oder sowas, haben Probleme mit der Polizei bekommen. Das ist nicht das Schlimme. Das Sprechen habe ich dann auch gelassen. Ich habe die Leute direkt einfach angesprochen. Aber man sieht auch immer, das ist einfach die Erfahrung. Man sieht, welche Leute Tickets haben und dann weiß man, welche Leute sie einfach loswerden wollen und reingehen wollen. Und die muss man halt abfangen. Und dann gibt es noch die Leute, die überzogene Preisvorstellungen haben und die sind dann auch meistens schnell runtergegangen, weil es eben de facto keinen Schwarzmarkt gab, so wie ich es von anderen Turnieren kannte. Und dann konnte man dann auch sagen, ja gut, lass uns mal eine halbe Stunde reden, dann wirst du froh sein, wenn du das Geld nimmst, das ich dir biete. So läuft es eigentlich. Und ich muss auch sehen, ich gehe da alleine rein. Ich habe immer Leute, mit denen ich reise, die treffe ich immer wieder mal oder ich spontan reise. Ich bin zwar allein losgeflogen, aber ich bin da immer mit verschiedenen Leuten gereist. Deswegen muss ich auch nur noch ein Ticket gucken. Wir haben auch immer zusammen nach drei Tickets geguckt. Dann holen wir uns halt die Tickets so zusammen. Das heißt natürlich, man kommt in die Blöcke nicht rein, aber wenn man das lang genug macht, weiß man auch, wenn man in die andere Blöcke reinkommt, man kriegt das irgendwie hin und dann sitzt man am Schluss eh da zusammen. Also so gesehen ist das weniger schwierig als man denkt. Für mich ist das kein Triller. Für mich gehört es irgendwie sogar dazu. Und außerdem habe ich keine Lust, ganz ehrlich, diese enormen, horrenden Preise zu zahlen für Spieler, die teilweise echt nicht dieses Geld wert sind. Ich will gerne die Spiele sehen, ich will gerne die Stadien sehen, aber ich frage mich manchmal, ob so ein Vor- und ein Spiel, wie es war das letzte Zaranz, habe ich glaube ich gesehen, das war das Panama gegen Tunisien oder was war das, glaube ich? Ah, 2 zu 1? Ja, ob ich da irgendwie 105 Dollar zahlen würde, das wäre es mir einfach nicht wert. Und dann ist es natürlich auch klar, dass die Antife Schwarzmarkt deutlich günstiger und besser ist.
Sind es so die normalen FIFA-Preise, also dreistellig 100 Euro aufwärts oder was waren so die Ticketpreise?
Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich habe mich da auch nicht so groß beschäftigt. Ich mache mir mal kurz einen Screenshot von den Preisen, dass ich weiß, was auf mich zukommt. Dann habe ich gewusst, okay, so viel wurde mir abgebucht für die Deutschland-Tickets. Das habe ich, die brauche ich, die brauchte ich, um die Fan-Attity zu bekommen. Und da wollte ich auch ganz sicher gehen, dass ich reinkomme. Und um vorstellen zu können, ich habe für die drei Deutschland-Tickets habe ich zusammen, glaube ich, 315 Dollar gezahlt. Das habe ich für die anderen Spiele zusammengerechnet, für die anderen neun nicht gezahlt, weil ich es einfach nicht ausgeben will und weil es auch nicht wert gewesen wäre. Das sind die günstigen Tickets für uns. Es gab noch eine Kategorie 4. Ich glaube, das hatte ich so auch mal besprochen mit dem Gespräch von dir vor zwei Jahren mit einem. Die für die Einheimischen, die gab es auch in Russland, waren nur wenige Tickets. Die Kategorie 4, die kam dann, glaube ich, vielleicht umgerechnet zu 20 Dollar oder Euro gekostet. Von denen gibt es nur verschwindend wenige und die nehmen auch die Einheimischen gerne. Ich habe auch mal so Tickets gekauft. Zum Beispiel habe ich mir absichtlich eines besorgt, auch jetzt zu Hendrik, in Yekaterinburg, weil ich unbedingt auf der Tribüne sitzen wollte, die außerhalb des Stadions steht. Das war einfach mein Ziel, und da habe ich mir auch so etwas besorgt und habe mich in die letzte Reihe oben hingesetzt, weil ich einfach das mal angucken wollte, wie das bei dem Stadion geht.
Du saß da ganz oben auf dieser reinen Stahlrohrtribüne. Bist du schwindelfrei, Hendrik?
Nein, ich bin ich echt nicht. Aber es war einfach so interessant, ein Stadion zu haben, wo man von rein guckt und wenn man daneben links und rechts rausguckt, guckt man über die Stadt. Ich fand es gigantisch, es war toll, mal was anderes zu sehen. Und damit hatte das Stadion schon was besonderes im Vergleich zu den anderen Stadionen, wo genau so, ich weiß nicht, in Sinzheim oder so stehen könnten zum Teil.
Aber das war lustigerweise, also was du gerade sagst, dass du Nils unbedingt mal dieses Stadion wolltest. So ging es mir halt auch. Also als, ich weiß nicht, so von einem halben Jahr oder von einem Jahr so bei den sozialen Medien, die ersten Bilder so rumgingen, das ist übrigens das Stadion in die Katharinenburg und so sieht es wirklich aus. Und wie krass ist das denn? Dachte ich, ja das ist das, da möchte ich hin. Und ja, da war ich dann. Saß leider nicht auf dieser Stahlrohrtribüne. Ich bin, als ich das erste Mal dort ankam, stand ich halt dahinter. Dachte mir auch, um Gottes Willen, das sieht schon einigermaßen halbsbrecherisch aus. Aber die, ich weiß nicht, die russische Stahlrohrtribünen-Baukunst hat da glaube ich echt ganze Arbeit geleistet. Also das, ich weiß nicht, du kannst ja mal beschreiben, wie war das denn? Also ich fand, das hat halt wirklich so ein bisschen was so, mir das so vorgestellt, wie wenn man so in der Achterbahn irgendwie ganz oben ist, bevor es dann abwärts geht.
Naja, das ist ein bisschen wie, wenn man auf die Bühnen bei einer Rennstrecke geht, die sind manchmal auch so aufgebaut oder temporäre Debüten bei DFP-Bokal spielen. Aber mir hat das sehr gereizt. Vor allem war da auch interessant, dass ich da das Einzige war noch so ein Bändchen bekommen habe, weil natürlich da in diesen Stahlrohrtribünen haben sie zum Beispiel keine Essensstände reinbauen können. Sprich, man musste in der Pause runterlaufen, das ging ewig und dann wieder zu den Ständen gehen, die außerhalb waren. Das habe ich gar nicht gemacht, weil ich mir war klar, dass da komme ich nie wieder rechtzeitig rein zum Anpfiff oder sowas. Ansonsten fand ich, dass die Dinger waren natürlich top gebaut und ich fand es auch wirklich interessant. Und wie gesagt, es ist schon was komisches. Ich war auch froh, dass es nicht geregnet hat, weil sonst wäre es nicht so toll gewesen, in der letzten Reihe da oben zu sitzen und nass zu werden. Aber es war Besonderes und sowas vergisst man eben nicht, im Gegensatz zu anderen Stadien und Spielen, glaube ich.
Das glaube ich. Aber wie weit weg war man da, vom Spielfeld? Kannst du es vergleichen mit anderen Stadien, in denen du warst, die vielleicht der ein oder andere Hörer kennt?
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Also erstens sitzt man immer im Freien. Also außerhalb des Stadions, das ist schon besonderer. Zweitens sitzt man ohne Dach. Das ist ja heute bei Stadien kaum noch der Fall. Da musst du schon in die alten Stadien zurückgehen. Ich habe da einen Artikel drüber gelesen, glaube ich. Dann hat jemand es verglichen wie mit mit Praga. Da war ich auch bei der EM. Das hat schon was besonderes. Man vergisst einfach nicht, dass man in so einem Stadion war. Ansonsten die Stimmung. Klar, irgendwann sind die Leute darauf gekommen, dass sie da mit den Füßen trampeln müssen. Da gibt es so ein Geräusch, was aber auch nicht übermäßig laut war. Ich meine, trotzdem muss ich sagen, jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo vielleicht noch interessanter ist, vielleicht ein bisschen langweiliger ist. Ich fand das Stadion deswegen clever, weil man einfach das dann zurückbaut und hat ein Stadion, was vielleicht der ganzen Stadt oder der ganzen Fußball dort angemessen ist. Man hat dann eben nicht ein Stadion stehen, was noch nicht ein Riesenthema ist, was wahrscheinlich auch Hendrik bestätigen kann. Oder was auch du auch weißt, wo dann in der Landschaft rumstehen, was mit anderen Stadionen in Russland erfaltet wird. Also so gesehen, was Besonderes und dann noch klüger gedacht, muss ich sagen.
Ich fand, da war vorher dieses alte Zentralstadion, glaube ich, was so eine alte Sowjet-Fassade hat und die war auch noch da. Und da haben sie dann das neue Stadion, also der, was jetzt nicht Stahlrohr-Tribüne ist. Der Rest des Stadions sieht so ein bisschen so aus wie so ein Kochtopf, den hat man einfach reingestellt. Und ich finde, das war auch einfach ein schönes Stadion. Das hatte irgendwie was und das hatte jetzt nicht nur diese Besonderheit mit diesen Stahlrohr-Dingern. Das sah einfach auch hübsch aus. Und wie du sagst, man baut es zurück, hat dann ein Stadion für, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, 23.000 Zuschauer oder so, für den Club, der dort spielt. Und das hat dann sogar noch eine Anschlussverwendung. Und man hat dann nicht diesen klassischen weißen Elefanten, wie das sogenannte Standort in der Falle.
Da kann ich mich nicht nur anschließen, was du gesagt hast, Hendrik. Genau, das sind auch die Gründe. Und das habe ich auch so wahrgenommen, so sehe ich es auch. Und das ist halt jetzt der Punkt, was mit den weißen Elefanten und das ist natürlich auch eine Geschichte, was auch ich bei anderen Turnieren schon erlebt habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dort warst. Eine Stadion ewig weit außen. Ich glaube, das wird keinen Menschen mehr so richtig nutzen. Unglaublich teuer und sowas.
Da war ich nicht, leider. Aber ist Samara, dieses Stadion, was aussieht, das hat ja glaube ich auch jemand bei Twitter geschrieben, wie dieses Stadion aus diesen Champions League Spots.
Genau, es ist sternförmig und so ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, genau, wo man denkt, so ein Fantasiestart, so was baut doch niemand.
Genau, ich will nicht wissen, wie das in zehn Jahren aussieht, wenn das keiner nutzt und bei der Baustanz. Deswegen, weil wir eh wissen, wie das alles Geld gekostet hat. Ich will es nicht erdenken, diesen Moralapostel-Spiel und sowas, aber das ist schon ein wichtiges Argument.
Wie ist denn das, wenn wir jetzt schon bei der Eigenart der Stadien sind? Im Fernsehen sieht ja alles gleich aus. Also ja, da ragen noch mal so Stadien wie Sochi und St. Petersburg vielleicht ein bisschen raus. Da hat man dann auch noch mehr so Lufthelikoptershots, die ein bisschen mehr von der Stadt zeigen. Aber so, wie das Spiel übertragen wird, sieht ein Stadion aus wie das andere. Und wenn ich irgendwo auf einer Bande groß stünde, in welchem Ort man sich gerade befindet, man würde es nicht erkennen. Und das ist ja auch so gewollt. Es ist ja alles genormt. Es hat alles die gleichen Farben, die gleichen Schriften und so weiter. Wie weit muss man denn, Hendrik, von so einem WM-Stadion weggehen, um dann was von der Stadt mitzubekommen und nicht mehr quasi dieses FIFA-Labeling und diese ewig gleiche FIFA-Welt zu sehen?
Tja, das kommt so ein bisschen darauf an. Also hier in Katharinenburg zum Beispiel, wo wir darüber gesprochen haben, da war dieses Stadion direkt am Westrand der Innenstadt. Und wenn man dann zehn Minuten zu Fuß gelaufen ist, dann war man auf so einem der zentralen Plätze. Da steht dann wie überall an den zentralen Plätzen eine große Lenin-Statue und ein riesen Einkaufszentrum.
Das ist ja auch eine Ironie, eine Lenin-Statue und ein Einkaufszentrum.
Ja, das ist aber die Bilder bei Twitter, die ihr wahrscheinlich auch gesehen habt, von dem Blushniki, wo sie den FIFA-Fanshop direkt vor die Lenin-Statue gebaut haben. Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen. Genau, und da ist man natürlich in der Innenstadt und kriegt schon so ein bisschen was mit von dieser Stadt auch. Aber trotzdem ist da natürlich auch noch alles FIFA-gelabelt. Da sind überall die Fahnen, da sind überall die FIFA-Fanshops. Da stehen dann auch diese Sabiwaka-Figuren, also von diesem Maskottchen. Von daher, glaube ich, muss man dann schon sehr weit weggehen. Ich hatte in einer Stadt eine Unterkunft, die war wirklich ein bisschen weiter draußen, wo der Taxifahrer dann auch fragte, hier wohnst du wirklich? Ich meinte, ja, warum nicht? Und da sah es dann schon sehr nach dem Russland aus, wie man sich das vielleicht schlechterweise vorstellt. Da wurden die Straßen plötzlich nicht mehr alle drei Stunden gesäubert. Und da waren dann auch nicht alle Bürgersteige frei von Zigarettenstummeln und Kaugummis und so was. Das war dann schon irgendwie anders. Aber so um die Stadien rum war schon eigentlich überall diese FIFA-Welt. Oder auch so in den Innenstädten war das so. Ich kann mich erinnern, in Nijnjnovka zum Beispiel, was ich eine sehr nette Stadt fand, da liegt das Stadion. Auf der linken Seite des Flusses, da fließen die Wolga und die Oka zusammen. Also sehr viel Wasser, sieht auch sehr beeindruckend aus von außen. Auf der anderen Seite des Flusses ist dann so die Innenstadt, die liegt dann auch so erhöht. Und von da hat man einen super Blick über die Stadt und auch über diesen Zusammenfluss. Aber da ist dann auch die Zentrale Straße, ist natürlich auch komplett FIFA-Land gewesen in den letzten vier Wochen.
Also ich kann mich dann nur anschließen, was Hendrik erzählt hat. Man konnte dem ein bisschen kommen. Also ich bin auch Läufer, deswegen hatte ich meine Joggen-Schuhe dabei. Ich bin auch laufen gegangen. Da war ich schnell weg aus diesem Bereich. Ansonsten habe ich auch immer, wenn ich mit den Leuten geredet habe, versucht, die Volontiers oder die Leute anzusprechen und wollte sagen, okay, wo kann ich hier essen gehen, einheimisch? Und dann war der erste Satz, da vorne ist McDonalds, da ist Subway, und ich so nein, ich würde gerne einheimisch essen gehen. Ich habe dann mit einem Person Essen rausgesucht, die ich gerne probieren wollte. Dann waren sie erst irritiert und dann erfreut. Dann habe ich gesagt, nein, ich finde es nicht teuer, ich finde es nicht billig, wo würdest du mir empfehlen, wo ich essen gehe, zum Beispiel? Und so habe ich versucht, das Ganze anzunähern. Das war dann auch viel angenehmer. Dann bist du in ein Restaurant gelandet, wo vielleicht nicht nur Fans waren. Ich will es nicht verteufeln, aber das ist eben auch mein Impuls. Ich will immer auch das Land sehen, wie es wirklich ist. Wie Hendrik sagt, da landet so ein FIFA-Raumschiff in jeder Stadt, und da rum ist alles abgesperrt und nur Labeling und sonst was. Dieses schlimme Wort Commerz-Fußball ist da präsent und ist einfach klar. Und alles sauber, perfekt. Aber mir zu perfekt. Da bin ich Fußballfan, da will ich die Spiele sehen, aber außen rum brauche ich es so nicht. Wie er erzählt hat, wenn man dann beide rausgefahren ist, war man so wirklich dann, anführungsstrichen, war in Russland. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen, weil ich mich da auch nicht so gut auskenne. Aber es ging dann schon einfach. Einmal mit der U-Bahn, nicht in den ersten Ring, in Moskau, nach den ersten Stationen aussteigen, schon einmal ganz rausfahren, da sieht es dann ganz anders aus. Das war dann schon sehr, sehr viel interessanter.
Ich hatte noch so eine Erfahrung, wenn es gerade darum geht, vielleicht so das richtige Russland kennenzulernen. Da waren wir auch in Irkaterinburg mit einem Kollegen, da war ich schon unterwegs und wir hatten den Nachmittag frei und wollten ins Spiel gucken. Und dann haben wir auch überlegt, wo geht man jetzt hier hin, wenn man nicht aufs Fanfest will, was wir nicht wollten. Und dann haben wir geguckt, so Fußballbar, Irkaterinburg, haben wir da was gefunden, was da empfohlen wurde. Und da dachten wir, das sieht doch irgendwie ganz nett aus, kann man hinlaufen, versuchen wir mal. Sind dann da hin und dann schon so, das war dann am Ende von so einer Einkaufsstraße und die Straße ging dann schon zu Ende. Ich dachte, jetzt sind wir wahrscheinlich dran vorbeigelaufen. Nee, jetzt geradeaus, weiter geradeaus. Na ja, und dann wurde es auch immer dunkler. Und dann auch so, ja, hier unten musste es sein. Und dann musste man so eine Treppe runter in so einen Keller und kamen wir dann rein, der Laden relativ dunkel und auch irgendwie der ganze Laden so dekoriert mit Aufklebern von Senni St. Petersburg, Hooligans und so weiter. Die zwei Jungs hinter der Theke, die waren auch recht sportlich, würde ich mal sagen, und kurze Haare. Und das war schon so, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie habe ich mich nicht so ganz gut wohlgefühlt im Laden und meinte auch zu meiner Begleiterin, lasst mich lieber raus, aber da hat er sich dann schon angefangen mit dem Mitteln und Enden der Bar zu verquatschen und direkt schon das Bier bestellt. Na gut, dann bleiben wir hier. Das war so ein bisschen, das fand ich so ein bisschen spooky. Und im Endeffekt war es dann aber so, dass der ganze Laden im Laufe des Nachmittags von Peruanern geflutet wurde. Und dann war es eh egal, wo man da war. Aber das war so ein Moment, wo ich gedacht habe, so, das ist vielleicht zumindest auch ein Stück von dem richtigen Russland.
Aber das heißt ja, dass, wenn man das nicht aktiv irgendwie sucht, wenn man als Fan vor Ort ist, dann sieht man doch eigentlich nur diese FIFA-Welt, wenn ich euch jetzt richtig verstehe.
Ja, ja, einen würde ich sagen. Also natürlich ist, ich habe das neulich in einem anderen Podcast gehört, und fand das ja nicht ganz treffend, die WM findet ja nicht in Ländern statt, sondern die findet in FIFA-Land in Ländern statt. Also wie du sagst, da landet halt so ein Raumschiff. Und man sieht dann als Fan oder als Journalist vielleicht noch mehr, wenn man in dieser Journalistenblase drin ist, halt immer nur einen Ausschnitt von einem Ausschnitt. Trotzdem ist das, was man sieht, findet ja in diesen Städten statt. Also auch wenn man durch die Einkaufsstraßen läuft, wo überall FIFA-Branding ist und FIFA-Merch verkauft wird, sieht man ja trotzdem, wie es dort aussieht, wie die Architektur aussieht, was dort für Geschäfte sind, was es für Restaurants gibt. Und in den Innenstädten ist auch nicht alles Starbucks, sondern McDonalds. Von daher fühlt sich so eine WM in Russland natürlich noch mal anders an als eine WM in Frankreich zum Beispiel. Und ich würde sagen, dass man auch, wenn man sich nur in dieser FIFA-Welt wehkriegt, kriegt man trotzdem ein Stück von dem Land auch mit. Aber natürlich viel weniger, als wenn man das macht wie du, Nils, was ich echt auch cool finde, sowas bewusst zu suchen, wenn du sagst, du gehst auch mal dorthin, wo jetzt nicht nur die Touristen hingehen, oder fragst auch ganz konkret nach Orten, wo man halt Einheimische trifft.
Also ich wollte mich jetzt da nicht irgendwie hinaustellen, um Gottes Willen, das war nicht meine Intention.
Nein, Quatsch, aber es ist die einen Reisen ja so und die anderen Reisen so. Und ich finde das total spannend, wenn du halt sagst, dass du halt schon auch ein bisschen was von dem echten Russland mitbekommen willst, oder auch sagst, du guckst dir mal ein Amateurspiel an.
Vor allem das auch noch in einem Land, in dem die Quote der englisch sprechenden Menschen nicht so hoch ist wie in anderen Ländern. Also ich war selbst einmal in Russland, das ist schon ganz ganz lange her, da fühle ich mich sehr alt, wenn ich mich daran zurückrenne, das war meine Kollegstufenfahrt. Und ja, es ist nicht so ganz einfach, sich zu verständigen, wenn du nicht lesen kannst, was auf den Schildern steht, weil es in diesem verdammten Kyrillisch geschrieben ist, wo jeder Buchstabe, der eine Ähnlichkeit hat, zu einem Buchstaben, den man kennt, definitiv ein anderer ist. Und wo du eben viel mit Leuten zu tun hast, wo du mit Englisch nicht weiterkommst. Und dann mit Händen und Füßen, das geht dann immer besser, von Tag zu Tag, aber deswegen habe ich da auch echt großen Respekt vor Nils. Und ich muss dich vor allem fragen, was waren denn die kulinarischen Highlights, die du da gegessen hast?
Gerne, also ich kann auch ganz kurz zu diesem, mit dem Kyrillisch, das denkt man natürlich, dass es krass werden würde, aber da kann ich auch zu Händen sagen, da die FIFA auch wirklich, oder auch der russische Staat, schon viel geleistet hat. Da waren so viele, im Bahnhof zum Beispiel, alles auch noch in unserer Sprache, in Lateinisch. Also sprich, man konnte immer alles auch verstehen, gar kein Problem. Und die Volunteer waren auch, hat man geguckt, dass es zum Beispiel die Leute, die da an den Zentralenpunkten standen, dass es Studenten waren, also Englisch-Kunden, und das fand ich eh schon toll. Also ich kann nur Englisch, ich kann nicht andere Sprachen, deswegen darf ich schon gar nicht erwarten, dass sie mehr können als Englisch. Und eigentlich müsste ich ja mindestens Russisch sprechen, wenn ich schon in ein anderes Land reise, aber damit hatte ich gar keine Probleme. Klar ist man in Verständigung ein bisschen schwieriger, aber das ist gar kein Problem. Und da hatte ich auch keine Bedenken vorher, und da wurde ich auch gar nicht enttäuscht. Aber ich kann es euch auch vorstellen, ich habe das wie gesagt bei diesem Eintritt in die Suburbs von Moskau gemerkt, als ich dann irgendwann auch ein Fußballspiel angucken wollte und davor noch im Fernsehen, da hat mich keiner verstanden. Irgendwann habe ich mich so halb durchgefragt, dann bin ich in so einer Weinkneipe gelandet, also eher so ein Absturz für Alkoholiker. Was aber sehr toll war, die Leute haben irgendwann gecheckt, dass ich Deutscher bin, wollten alle mit mir reden, Fotos machen und haben ja Deutsch ausgegraben. Also wirklich, dass man sich wohlgefühlt hat, ich wollte mich gar nicht mehr gehen lassen. Das war richtig ein Kram. Da habe ich gefühlt, okay, die haben nicht zu diesem ganzen Kosmos gehört. Die haben gewusst, okay, da läuft irgendwo 50 Kilometer weiter, da läuft ein Spiel in Moskau ab. Aber das hat gar nichts mit den Leuten da zu tun. Und das war sehr interessant. Das war der eine Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist mit dem Essen. Leider habe ich auch nicht so viel probiert. Klar, Borsch und so weiter, das probiert jeder. Ist auch ganz toll, also kann man nur empfehlen. Darum versuche ich immer so eine Kette zu finden, wo ich sage, das ist einheimisch. Da habe ich mich ein bisschen erkundigt. Ich habe auch Leute, die sich in Moskau verabredet haben, die sich in Moskau verabredet haben. Die haben uns vor dem Deutschland-Spiel gegen Mexiko durch die Stadt geführt und gesagt, geh dahin essen. Da gibt es so eine Kette, die heißt, ich weiß nicht, wie ich ausspreche, Mumu. Und das ist so, wo die einheimischen Essen gehen. Das gibt es auch oft in so großen Einkaufszentren, aber glaube ich nur in St. Petersburg und in Moskau. Das kenne ich ein bisschen. Gab es in Polen auch, gab es in Ukraine auch bei der EM. Und da kommt bei Münz dann die einheimischen Speisen essen. Nicht die allerbestekulierte, aber wirklich ausreichend. Und dann hat man halt rausgefunden, okay, der Borscht schmeckt mir. Oder ich mag diese, ich weiß immer noch nicht, wie es heißt, Pelmeni oder Pelmenia, keine Ahnung. Das sind so Teigtaschen wie Ravioli, die kann man verschieden füllen und dippen und gekocht oder geprutzelt. Sehr lecker, wirklich zu empfehlen. Und die habe ich dann einfach in jeder Stadt versucht auszuprobieren. Manchmal gab es sie, manchmal nicht. Und wenn nicht, ich glaube, das war auch in Kasan zum Beispiel, da habe ich andere Teigtaschen ausprobiert, weil ich gehört habe, okay, Tatastan, das ist der hier Spezialität, gucke ich danach, wer hat sowas, frage einen Einheimischen. Und der hat mich dahin geschickt. Also, da darf man nicht Kalibierungsängste haben, aber das ist auch gar kein Problem. Schmeckt alles super. Und ich könnte mich auch dazu dazu kennenlernen. Und eben nicht nur, Entschuldigung, dieses Bashing, aber nur zu McDonalds zu rennen und dann den russischen McDonalds-Soup, ja, zu gebrauchen.
Da werden die Journalisten vermutlich nicht ganz so verwöhnt worden sein in den entsprechenden Medienbereichen, Hendrik.
Ja, wobei da auch die Auswahl vergleichsweise groß war, würde ich sagen.
Also es gab immer Salat, es gab auch Einheimische Sachen oder nur von den vielen Sponsoren?
Nee, es gab dann zum Teil auch Einheimische Sachen. Also diese Pimeni gab es zum Beispiel auch in verschiedenen Varianten und allerhand verschiedene Sorten Fleisch und Fisch und so was. Aber wenn man das dann vier Wochen lang immer das gleiche hat, dann kommt das halt auch zu den Ohren raus. Und bei mir kommt die Schwierigkeit zu, ich esse kein Fleisch. Und das war dann in Russland, war es zum Teil ein bisschen kompliziert.
Gut, du bist hoffentlich nicht von selbigen Gefallen. Mich würde mal interessieren die Stimmung in den Stadien und auch das ganze Setup in den Stadien. Wenn man den Taktikstream sich angemacht hat und nicht das Fernsehbild hatte, dann hatte man eigentlich einen ganz guten Eindruck von der Beschallung. Und ich fand die Nils unfassbar laut. Also immer vor dem Anpfiff lief er noch mal so eine Techno-House-Dance-Nummer, bis dann endlich der Countdown kam und in jedem Stadion hat das gescheppert ohne Ende. Und ich dachte mir, meine Güte, das war schon damals bei der WM in Polen und bei der EM in Polen und Ukraine so, dass das sehr laut war. Bei der EM 2016 hatte ich das auch Eindruck. Aber irgendwie ist mir das bei jedem Spiel aufgefallen. War der Pegel vor Ort denn auch so laut oder kam das jetzt nur bei mir so rüber?
Ich muss dir sagen, ich bin zwar gewohnt, dass das von dir zu dir deutlich hervorgehoben wird. Das ist ja klar, es ist durchgetaktet und was gespielt wird. Ich glaube, es lief auch immer TNT von ACDS und Countdown und so.
Ja, es laufen immer die gleichen.
Ja, genau. Und oft gehe ich zu den Spielen erst, weil ich das Stadion sehen will, weil es ein toller Augenblick ist. Und das Stadion zum ersten Mal sieht. Aber es geht komplett an mir vorbei. Das ist für mich so, dass ich das komplett ausblende. Aber natürlich wird damit auch die Fans überlagert. Wenn es die geben würde, dann Stimmung machen würde. Bei manchen Spielen gab es das, bei manchen nicht. Das kann Hendrik sehr gut erzählen von den Peruanern, die sich einen Ruf erworben haben, allein der sich schon nur unterwegs war und gehört hat, was die Peruaner in Yekaterinburg, die 20.000 angeblich angestellt haben, da haben alle von geschwärmt. Da habe ich gesagt, ja gut, ich war bei Spielen, wo teilweise von nur 2.000 Landsmittern von einem Land dabei waren. Da war da nicht viel mit Stimmung. Dann ist es natürlich schade, wenn das so gewesen wäre, dass die Musik das übertönt hätte. Ansonsten, ich bin es da nicht anders gewöhnt, selbst wenn ich in das Grünwalder gehe, hauen die zwischen schon die Lautsprecher so auf und der Lautsprecher so laut. Ich bin es nicht anders gewöhnt und finde das traurig, aber leider schon dran gewöhnt.
Ja, ich finde, es kommt tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen darauf an, welche Länder dort gespielt haben oder welche Fangruppen, also die Südamerikaner, die ja traditionell sehr viele Fans mitbringen. Die machen dann schon auch vorm Spiel ein bisschen Stimmung. Und gerade die Peruaner, die du ansprichst, die sind ein bisschen verliebt bei der WM. Das war schon beeindruckend, wie viele da waren mit was für einer Euphorie, die dort waren, wohl wissend, dass ihre Mannschaft wahrscheinlich nichts reisen wird bei diesem Turnier. Dann im Endeffekt sie aber doch einen echt guten Eindruck gemacht haben. Und wenn sie dieses Spiel gegen Dänemark, was sie halt hätten gewinnen können, gewinnen, boah, das wäre vielleicht noch ganz anders gelaufen. Aber ich fand das total beeindruckend. Und auch diese Gesänge, die man dann das Spiel über gehört hat, die ja dann auch immer so, die südamerikanische, das klingt dann ja auch immer so sehr besonders. Das war schon echt beeindruckend. Da konnte man sich auch ein bisschen drin verlieren, wenn das Spiel vielleicht gerade nicht so viel her gab. Und ich habe ein Erlebnis auch gehabt, da war ich mit einem Kollegen an einem Abend auch in so einer Art Sports Bar, das ist eine andere als die vorhin beschriebene. Ein bisschen größer, ein bisschen heller. Wir wollten halt auch Spiel gucken und das war irgendwie zwei Tage nachdem Peru dort gespielt hatte. Und es waren aber noch alle möglich, also sehr viele Peruaner noch da. Und wir hatten die Spieljahres geschaut und haben dann schon gemerkt, naja, so nach und nach fühlt sich dieser Laden mit Peruanern. Und irgendwann haben die halt die Leinwarte ausgeschaltet und, ich bin noch ein Spiel auf dem kleinen Fernseher gezeigt, und dann haben die Peruaner die YouTube-Playlist übernommen und dann dort so Peruanische Heimatmusik gespielt. Und das hat mich so ein bisschen irgendwie an Kölner Karneval erinnert. Also irgendwann lagen sich alle in den Armen und haben geschunkelt und geheult und von zu Hause gesungen. Also ich fand das irgendwie total berührend auf eine Art. Und haben dann auch mein Kollegen und mich, die eben halt offensichtlich keine Peruaner sind, da total mit integriert und alle haben da irgendwie mitgemacht. Aber das war irgendwie total ein nettes Erlebnis. Und dann sind das dann irgendwie so Sachen, die man so neben der Strecke irgendwie mitnimmt, die mit dem Sport nicht zu tun haben, die aber trotzdem, ja, dann so ein Turnier halt dann irgendwie, die dann halt auch einfach hängen bleiben. Und ja, ansonsten zu dieser, vielleicht noch mal auf diese Anfangsfrage zurückzukommen, zu dieser Beschallung, also ich fand das auch extrem. Ich verstehe es auch nicht, warum man Fans nicht die Möglichkeit gibt, sich vor dem Stadion, vor dem Spiel vielleicht ein bisschen einzusingen. Aber das ist ja dann was, was es ja in der Bundesliga mittlerweile auch nicht mehr gibt und in der Champions League auch nicht mehr gibt. Also das muss man glaube ich mittlerweile in Kauf nehmen, dass es bis zum Anpfiff, dass es noch diesen Countdown gibt. Also bis das Spiel wirklich angepfiffen wird, wird man ja beschallt. Ja, das ist so. Und ich habe dann aber auch einige zu der Stimmung, einige Spieler erlebt, wo man das Gefühl hat, da sind jetzt überhaupt keine Fans von den beteiligten Mannschaften. Was man dann immer daran erkennt hat, dass irgendwann die Russia-Russia-Ufe sehr laut wurden. Also was man den Leuten ja auch nicht verdenken kann, wenn die eine WM im eigenen Land haben, dass die dann diese WM auch feiern. Aber das finde ich dann aber schade, wenn du halt dort irgendwie Kroatien, Dänemark spielst und vielleicht zum Beispiel bei Kroatien waren schon viele da, wo man halt einen Spieler hat und die Stimmung mit dem Spieler überhaupt nichts zu tun hat. Das ist halt ein bisschen schade, aber gibt es ja auch Gründe für, oder gibt es immer so Gründe, warum das dann mit der WM so war.
Du hast einen interessanten Punkt angesprochen, Hendrik. Also, ich habe mich früher bei anderen Turnieren Gedanken gemacht, wenn ich mir Karten von den Stadien geholt habe, okay, da spielt eine europäische Mannschaft. Es ist schwieriger, Tickets zu bekommen als zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt eine südamerikanische Mannschaft spielt. In diesem Turnier war es andersrum. Das hast du auch gemerkt. Die Fans aus den südamerikanischen Ländern waren deutlich präsenter als die europäischen. Und ich glaube einfach, das hat viel dieses Bild oder dieses Problem, das gerade zwischen Europa und Russland zu tun ist. Und deswegen auch der Heimatschein, wo es nach Russland hieß, da habe ich keinen Bock zu reisen, da fahr mal lieber alleine. Und so waren es zwar vielleicht 7000 Deutsche in Sochi oder was auch immer, aber es waren halt dann wie gesagt 20.000 Piroana. Oder wenn die Mexikaner sind gereist, wie die blöden, Respekt davor. Die waren bei jedem Spiel, da waren so viele unterwegs, wenn die da waren, dann hast du geguckt, da wird es schwieriger mit den Karten und so weiter. Und das fand ich sehr krasser Wechsel zu den letzten Turnieren, wo ich war. Und das war schon interessant und bemerkenswert. Weil ich meine, von uns fliegst du in zwei, drei Stunden nach Moskau und die fliegen um die halbe Erde, um zu uns zu kommen. Was teurer ist, mehr Zeit kostet. Vor allem von ihren Währungen her, von Pesos, was auch immer. Es ist eh viel teurer. Ich muss auch sagen, natürlich können sich nur bestimmte Leute dort leisten, aber Respekt davor, dass man wirklich dann 15.000 bis 20.000 Mexikaner da war. Oder Peruaner oder 8.000 Kolumbianer. Und dann gebe ich dir recht, machen die Ehe. Ich mag die Gesänge auch dort. Die klingen sehr schön in den Ohren, höre ich auch gerne. Und das war schon sehr beeindruckend. Und dann, wenn halt nichts gegen den tollen Weltmeister zurecht. Weltmeister Frankreich, aber die Franzosen sind kein Fußballland. Und die Fans von denen sind also wirklich, muss man leider sagen, sehr schwach. Und die Deutschen sind sogar noch besser. Und die, die vielleicht gespielt haben in den letzten Spielen. Ja, ich würde einfach so sagen, das ist die Erfahrung aus sich, man erst in Turnieren. Ich habe nur gehört, dass, glaube ich, bei den letzten Frankreichspielen im Halbfinale nur noch 2.000 Franzosen, da waren nur 3.000. Was dann auch mit der Fanadie zu tun hat. Aber ich will nicht wissen, was, wenn dann Südamerikanes Land gespielt hätte, was da los gewesen wäre. Das ist ein bisschen schade, muss man sagen.
Ja, absolut. Ich habe das auch bei den, ich war bei tatsächlich allen Frankreichspielen, bis auf eins, glaube ich, bei Erdrich Zufall. Und da ist mir aber auch aufgefallen, dass das eigentlich, in den Städten hat man nie nennenswert Franzosen gesehen. In den Stadionen war nie so, dass man gesagt hat, hier ist jetzt die Frankreich-Kurve. Also es waren dann immer so ein paar Versprengte und gestern beim Finale war es auch so, oder am Sonntag beim Finale, waren dann so ein paar versprengte Franzosen. Aber dass man so richtig das Gefühl hat, hier ist jetzt wirklich ein Block mit ein paar tausend Leuten, das hatte man halt bei Frankreich überhaupt nicht. Also im Finale hatten die ein Auswärtsspiel gegen Kroatien und genau, steht aber auch vielleicht so ein bisschen, wie auch schon gesagt, stellvertretend für viele europäische Länder, dass man vielleicht nach Russland halt doch nicht so schnell oder so gerne reist. Also der verschiedene Gründe, die politischen sind die einen, aber auch Visum und so weiter ist einfach auch noch mal was anderes, hat ja wahrscheinlich auch damit zu tun.
Aber könnt ihr mir erklären, warum das so war, dass wenn du Fanblöcke gesehen hast, dass das immer nur so einzelne Punkte innerhalb von großen Mengen im Stadion war, also wir hatten ja nie richtige Kurven, dass du sagen kannst, okay, hier die Engländer, hier die Franzosen, das gab es ganz selten mal.
Also beim Finale war es tatsächlich so, dass man auf jeden Fall eine Kroatien-Kurve hatte, die sehr sehr groß war, das war dann von dem, wo die Journalisten saßen, und ich denke, das wird auch die Kameraposition gewesen sein, die rechte Seite, also da war alles voller Kroaten, wobei als dann das erste Tor für Frankreich fiel, habe ich gemerkt, da sind aber auch sehr sehr viele Franzosen, also es wurde da auch schon sehr laut gejubelt.
Die gehen in dem Karo einfach unter, das ist so ein optischer Trick, Hendrik. Und wenn man ganz lange drauf guckt auf die kroatische Kurve, dann sieht man ein Pferd.
Genau, wie in diesen 3D-Büchern früher, wo man auch so lange drauf guckt. Aber das zeigt ja irgendwie auch, dass möglicherweise die anderen Fans ja auch da waren, man hätte sie vielleicht einfach nur cleverer im Stadion platzieren können. Also das ist mir bei ganz vielen Spielen aufgefallen, dass man hier mal ein paar Schweden, da mal ein paar Schweden, da mal ein paar Schweden und dann war es immer hier mal gelb, da mal gelb, aber dass man es nicht geschafft hat, so eine Kurve zusammenzubringen. Und wenn du fragst, woran das liegt, ich kann es mir ehrlich gesagt nicht erklären. Wenn ich so ein Tool organisieren würde und die Karten dafür verkaufen müsste, dann würde ich doch zusehen, dass die Karten, die ich an ein Land verkaufe, in der einen Ecke des Stadions sind und die in ein Land wie andere Ecke des Stadions sind.
Also, wenn ich kurz zwischengrenzen darf, in der Vorrunde ist es einfacher, weil da sind die Spiele fix seit so und so vielen Monaten. Da kann man das planen. Das in der K.o.-Runde ist eh immer klar. Da hängt es natürlich mit den Preisen und Tickets zusammen. Die Schweden haben es gut hinbekommen. Die versuchen immer so Blöcke zu bilden. Das ging auch meistens gut, aber irgendwann bei der K.o.-Runde ist es halt so, dass dann die Leute sich da hinsitzen, wo sie Plätze kriegen und dann haben sie Optionstickets und die Tickets. Und einer kauft von dem wieder einen Konigent. Das ist klar. Und deswegen gibt es zum Beispiel auch keine Fan-Trading. Wenn man heute in den Bundesligastadion geht, dann werden da die Gäste-Fans hingeleitet. So was Gäste-Fans gibt es natürlich nicht. Aber es vermischt sich einfach alles, was natürlich die FIFA auch nicht, glaube ich, groß stört, weil so wirkt es viel ein einverschämt friedlicher. Ja, genau. Aber ich glaube, Hendrik, ich hätte schon gerne so, es ist schon toll, wenn du auf der einen Seite die einen Fans hast und auf der anderen Stadion die anderen. Und dann könnte es sich vielleicht auch nicht Utopie, aber wenn er vielleicht mal England oder gegen Deutschland gespielt hat vor, weiß ich, vor was war ich da in WM in Belgien vor Ewigkeiten, da war das schon klar, da waren die Engländer da und die Deutschen da. Und da gab es schon die Gesänge vielleicht hin und her und zumindest ein bisschen mehr. Und ob es das noch weiter so geben wird, weiß ich nicht. Denn ich glaube, die FIFA hat bei der Kartenvergabe und so ganz andere Prämissen, als da irgendwie Fanblöcke entstehen zu lassen, sondern da werden so viele 105-Euro-Tickets so wenig wie möglich, da werden viele Kategorie-2-Tickets mehr rausgehauen. Dann sollen die Sponsoren die besten Tickets bekommen und so weiter. Ich glaube, darauf nimmt die FIFA nicht wirklich Rücksicht, ganz ehrlich. Das ist ziemlich egal.
Ich finde es aber auch gut, dass du nochmal das Beispiel England nennst, die ja normalerweise, wenn England bei Turnieren mitspielt, dann fahren ja 10.000 Englander hin. Ich glaube, England hat die letzten Male immer auch das Ranking für die meisten Ticket-Verkäufe angeführt oder auf jeden Fall mit angeführt. Normalerweise, wenn England spielt, dann kommen die nicht einfach in Städte, sondern dann werden diese Städte eingenommen in einer gewissen Form. Klingt jetzt sehr martialisch, aber dann sieht man auf den zentralen Plätzen überall Englander, dann werden überall die Fahnen aufgehängt und so weiter. Und das hatte man jetzt in Russland wirklich, also zumindest was ich mitbekommen habe, hatte man das so nicht.
Ja, das finde ich eh ein interessantes Thema. Also zum einen erzählst du, Nils, dass man sehr einfach an Tickets gekommen wäre und dass es auch keinen klassischen Schwarzmarkt gab. Auf der anderen Seite hatten wir ein Spiel Ägypten gegen Uruguay. Das war am zweiten WM-Tag eben in Yekaterinburg. Da waren deutlich erkennbar viele Plätze frei. Und ab dann, wie durch ein Mirakel, waren die Stadien eigentlich relativ voll. Und Gianni Infantino sprach dann jetzt im Nachgang der WM von einer Stadienauslastung von 98 Prozent.
Das heißt, dass nach diesem Uruguay-Egypten alle anderen Spiele wahrscheinlich herausverkauft sein müssen.
Genau, wie war es denn wirklich so eurer Beobachtung nach? Oder könnt ihr mir überhaupt erklären, woher das kommen könnte, dass so viele Plätze frei waren? Oder dann aufgefüllt wurden irgendwie anders?
Also, wenn ich zuerst sprechen kann, klar, die Vorrunde kann man gut planen. Ein paar Monate vorher können die Leute planen. Meistens bleiben die Leute drei oder vier Wochen bei der WM. Das ist schon selten. Sprich, dann gehen die Tickets nur von Einheimischen. Ob die Einheimischen sich alle Spiele angucken wollen, da bezweifle ich. Und das hände ich gerade auch von den Mannschaften. Aber ich habe auch, wie gesagt, für das Spiel, wo ich Deutschland gegen Mexiko war, im größten Stadion in Moskau, da war der Schwarz-Brot-Torennt, da hatte ich ein Ticket, und dann wurden am Schluss, das war auch wirklich kein Witz, bis zu 800 Euro gezahlt. Grund? Moskau, viele Leute wollen das sehen, viele wollen Deutschland sehen, viele Mexikaner, große Stadt. Bei Kleinstädten, wenn nicht viele, nicht bekannte Mannschaften waren und so was, da waren einfach nur die Einheimischen hin. Und ich habe zum Beispiel auch, glaube ich, Tunesien kennengelernt am Flughafen, die haben mir erzählt, Tunesien ist ja aus Deutschland, und die haben mir erzählt, dass sie Tickets für viele hatten, dann haben sie gewusst, dass sie sie rausfliegen und haben gesagt, verlassen sie vorher schon Russland und lassen die letzten Tickets verfallen. Und so entsteht halt so eine Melange in den KO-Spielen, wo sagt es, die Tribünen wirken nicht voll und sie sind auch nicht voll gewesen. Ich wandere immer rum bei den Spielen, setze mich hin am Schluss, wo ich will, hole mir ein billiges Ticket und lande immer auf der Haupttribüne oder neben den Presseplätzen. Irgendwie geht es immer. Du bist ja der MacGyver der Stadion-Besucher. Na, so krass ist es nicht. Es geht wirklich einfach. Man muss nur einfach ganz locker alles angehen. Aber was ich sagen will, ist, das ist kein russisch-spezifisches Problem. Das ist oft bei KO unten so. Das ist nichts Neues, glaube ich. Deswegen, ich will es auch nicht so negativ auslegen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie dann bei den Nachdenken gemerkt haben, bei diesen Ägypten, was für ein Spiel, in Burguay, ob sie dann Leute reingesetzt haben. Ich kenne mich da nicht aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das gemacht haben. Aber ich war jetzt in keinem Stadion, außer diesem Deutschland-Mexiko-Spiel, wo es wirklich ausverkauft war. Und es gab immer noch viele Plätze. Aber es heißt nicht, dass es einen Schwarzmann gab. Warum die Karten nicht genommen wurden, ob sie dann Sponsorenkarten verfallen sind, ob die Einheimischen nicht hingegangen sind, was auch immer, weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist schade. Ich habe mir vorstellen können, dass Einheimische zu normalen Preisen auch gerne angeguckt hätten. Aber eine 105-Dollar-Karte für einen Einheimischen, für irgendwie so ein Spiel wie am Schluss, was ich jetzt gesehen habe in Sarans, zwischen Tunesien und noch was, wo Panama, wo eh ausgeschieden sind. Ob man das zahlen will, das verstehe ich dann schon, aber das ist keiner zahlen will.
Ja, aber das finde ich da schon total fehl genannt, was das halt erklärt, dass dann gerade in der K.o.-Runde die Stadien leer sind. Und ich kannte diesen Eindruck. Max wurde auch gefragt, hast du wieder unser Eindruck? Weil diesen Eindruck habe ich auch bestätigt. Es waren schon viele Spiele, wo die Stadien vergleichsweise leer aussahen. Also dieses Ugoa gibt sicher das Extrembeispiel. Da war ich auch und da war die Stimmung wirklich traurig. Aber ich kann mich auch erinnern, jetzt beim Halbfinale in St. Petersburg, Belgien gegen Frankreich, da waren auch wahnsinnig viele freie Plätze, so wie ich das gesehen habe. Und wir haben ja schon gesagt, die Franzosen, da waren es nicht so wahnsinnig viele Leute dabei gehabt. Und bei den Belgiern war es irgendwie ähnlich. Dann ist dieses Stadion, 65.000 Leute gehen da rein. Das muss man halt auch erstmal voll kriegen. Ja, und glaube ich, so kommen dann irgendwie viele Gründe zusammen. Und beim Spiel um Platz drei war es dann das gleiche. Also wieder in Langpetersburg. Und da kommt dann einfach zu, es ist ein Spiel um Platz drei. Es ist ein besseres Freundschaftsspiel. Vielleicht sogar ein schlechteres Freundschaftsspiel. Aber dass dann Leute sagen, dafür gebe ich jetzt nicht noch mal einen dreistelligen Betrag aus, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Naja, 98 Prozent. Ich will nur noch mal die Zahl genannt haben. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr da gesehen habt. Was wir da beobachtet haben. Aber gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass es in Russland während der WM WM-Stadion gab mit Alkoholgehalt, was es sonst nicht gibt. Da wird wohl der eine oder andere von euch regelmäßig zu tief in den Becher geschaut. Es tut mir leid, dass ich das jetzt hier mal so öffentlich sagen muss. Was war denn die Stadt, die euch am meisten in Erinnerung bleiben wird? Nils, fang mal an.
Schwer zu sagen. Meistens sind es immer dann auch die Mädchen von den Stadien ab, aber auch von den Städten, was ich da dran so erlebe. Ich habe da komplett verschiedene Erfahrungen gemacht. Wie gesagt, ich treffe immer Leute beim Reisen, die ich immer wieder mal treffe. Und die sagen, die Stadt ist toll, da komme ich dahin, fand ich die nicht so toll. Und andersrum. Ich fand Kaliningrad nicht so toll, da gab es ein bisschen mehr, aber ich dachte, okay, früher Richtung Ostpreußen, das könnte interessant sein. Fand ich nicht so toll. Ich fand Nizhinovka dort auch sehr interessant. Mir hat es sehr gefallen mit dem Kreml, das eigentlich fast in jeder Größe Stadt geht. Also diese Festung, wo man über die Wolga gucken kann und so, fand ich es. Oder über die Flüsse gucken kann, das finde ich immer sehr toll. Moskau ist ein Moloch, da muss man nicht zu WM gehen. Da kann man sich so mal in Ruhe angucken. Das kommt mir auch so mal hin. Aber ich finde es immer toll, in Städte zu gehen, wo man sonst wirklich nicht hinkommen würde, wenn man nicht zum Turnier gehen würde. Und so gesehen hat mir Wolgo gerade sehr gut gefallen. Denn erstens hat mich die Vergangenheit interessiert, muss ich auch zugeben. Das spricht, ich bin auch dann ins Weltkrieg-Museum gegangen. Und man weiß auch die Bedeutung für Russland vom großen Vaterländischen Krieg. Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Wie ist es, wenn man da als Deutscher ist?
Bei mir ist der Punkt, ich sehe nicht aus wie ein Deutscher und ich trete nicht auf wie ein Deutscher, deswegen habe ich das nie so wahrgenommen. Ich wollte nie als Deutscher bezeichnet, deswegen weiß ich gar nicht. Ich kann leider nicht mitreden, muss ich zugeben. Das Thema selbst, Politik, kann ich mal ganz kurz anreißen. Ich hatte mit einem, wie gesagt, der hat auch als Archivar gearbeitet, also durchaus ansprechende Diskussionen. Aber ich habe irgendwann das Thema dann fallen gelassen, denn es ging dann darum, warum unterstützt Merkel Putin nicht? Das ist doch offensichtlich, die Krim gehört zu uns und so weiter und so fort. Das war mir dann ein bisschen zu heil. Ich kenne uns da alle ein bisschen aus, habe es gelassen. Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, die wollten, jeder will in jedem Land, wo er ist, die Leute wissen, und gefällt dir Russland, ich finde das auch so toll. Und das habe ich auch gern bejaht, denn es hat mir eigentlich überall gefallen, muss ich zugeben. Ansonsten fand ich eben Volgograd so toll, weil das Wetter toll war, weil ich da mal zwei Tage war am Stück war und nicht gleich weitergereist bin, weil ich eben dieses Stadion auch schön war und da an der Wolga gelegen. Und da oben drüber auch, wahrscheinlich kennt ihr diese Mutter-Russland-Statue, die dann nach dem Krieg gebaut wurde. Und das hat so einen Streik, man konnte auch hochlaufen, sich das angucken, dann oben schön auf die Stadt blicken und auf der Stadion. Mir hat es sehr gut gefallen. Und auch die Geschichte, die hinten dran war, und das war schon sehr, wie ich sage, berührend, aber wenn man sich das vorstellt, 70, 80 Jahre davor, und was da passiert ist, und dann stehen wir hier und feiern, fand ich schon sehr, sehr krass. Ich weiß nicht, ob alle Leute das so gesehen haben, aber deswegen bin ich auch ins Museum rein. Und ich muss auch sagen, die Deutschen, die ich alle getroffen habe, die wollten auch alle ins Museum rein, sind auch ins Museum reingegangen. Die wollten das auch sehen, das Weltkrieg, das Museum, und durchaus Interesse an dem ganzen Paar. Ich meine, das ist ja auch sehr präsent. Ich meine, man sieht überall in der Stadt noch, wie gerade die Leningstadion, aber davon abgesehen auch oft noch Panzer, die grün lackiert sind und noch dastehen, oder wie oft hat jetzt jede Stadt ein Militärmuseum und so. Also dem gesehen weiß man schon, was Bedeutung das von der russischen oder zivilischen Identität hat.
Hendrik, an was wirst du dich wahrscheinlich noch länger erinnern, an welche Orte?
Ja, also kann ich erstmal genauso unterstreichen, was du, Nils, gesagt hast, zur Bedeutung des Zweiten Weltkriegs für Russland und diese Präsenz, die das halt noch in gewisser Form hat. Also alles, was du jetzt gesagt hast, habe ich genauso auch wahrgenommen. Ohne jetzt selbst in Wolberg gewesen zu sein. Von den Städten, die mir am meisten Erinnerungen bleiben, also ich meine, klar, Moskau zu sagen, ist irgendwie einfach. Moskau ist, wenn man hier ist, schon eine sehr beeindruckende Stadt. Aber da kommt man tatsächlich immer mal irgendwie hin. Von den Städten, die ich jetzt noch nicht, oder ich war vorhin schon einmal in Moskau gewesen, ich kannte das zumindest so ein bisschen. Von den Städten, in denen ich noch nie gewesen bin und ja, wo man vielleicht auch abseits von, wo man halt nicht um den hinkommt, fand ich auch nicht in die Nordkorea tatsächlich am besten. Weil dieser Blick über diese beiden Flüsse, das hatte schon echt was. Man hat dann so auch Richtung Stadion geschaut und von dem hohen Ufer auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite, das war schon wirklich beeindruckend. Ich habe da irgendwie ein paar echt nette Restaurants und Bars irgendwie gefunden, in denen ich dann Fußballspiele mir angeschaut habe. Ich habe eine Bar gefunden im Hinterhof, da habe ich mir das Englern-Kolumbienspiel angeschaut und da haben dann plötzlich alle Leute für England gejubelt. Man dachte auch irgendwie, es hieß doch, dass die Russen die Engländer nicht mögen. Also wo man dann auch so einen Reality-Check bekommt und dann merkt, es ist natürlich alles viel schichtiger, als man sich vorher irgendwie vorgestellt hat. Also von daher, was die Stadt an sich und aber auch die Leute und die Sachen, die man da so machen konnte, anging, da fand ich auch nicht aufgehört wirklich. Das wird auf jeden Fall in Erinnerung bleiben. Ich hab am letzten Tag eine Fahrt mit der Seilbahn über die Volga gemacht. Und wenn man dann noch mal merkt, was die Volga für ein wahnsinnig breiter Fluss ist, dass man mit dieser Seilbahn irgendwie 20 Minuten unterwegs ist, das ist unfassbar. Aber wirklich so, ja, das sind so Sachen, die erlebt man halt so schnell nicht wieder. Und von daher wird das absolut in Erinnerung bleiben.
Und welches war das schönste Stadion? War das bemerkenswerteste? Gut, über je Katharinenburg haben wir jetzt schon gesprochen.
Dürfen wir das nicht mehr nennen? Naja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin nicht unbedingt ein Fan von diesen hypermodernen Stadien. Aber wenn ein Stadion irgendwie so richtig groß ist und wie eine beeindruckende Aura hat, dann finde ich das schon spannend. Diese Stadion in St. Petersburg erschlägt einen, weil das so riesig ist, weil da oben noch diese Spitzen drauf sind, die über das Stadion hinausragen. Und wir wissen noch alle, wie wahnsinnig viel das gekostet hat und was für eine Verschwendung das war. Aber das ist, wenn man dort ist, ein beeindruckendes Fußballstadion.
Also man sieht die Verschwendung wenigstens auch.
Man sieht die Verschwendung auch. Und ich fand auch Luschniki wirklich ein sehr schönes Stadion. Auch ein sehr würdiges Finale-Stadion.
Also ich kann mich da eigentlich nur anschließen. Luschniki war vor, mit einer leichter ledigen Laufbahn, also was sie draus gemacht haben, Respekt davor. Das haben sie echt super hinbekommen. Ich fand Jürgen Riedenburg hat dich schon gesagt, fand ich interessant. Ansonsten fanden halt diese Stadion weg, die zugleich waren. Also Kaliningrad zum Beispiel und Rostov am Don. Das waren einfach, Entschuldigung, wie man sich einfach kennt. Ansonsten, ja, also ich bin über jede Stadion und froh, was eine Geschichte hat. Ich fand auch interessant, Sochi ist natürlich der komplett künstliche Badeort. Also das sind nur kleine Orte, dieser Hartler ist der Hauptort nebendran. Aber was man zum Stadion sagen muss, es hat eine besondere Architektur. Deswegen ist es schon wieder interessant, in dem gewesen zu sein. Denn man erkennt das sofort, ich bis sofort, es leuchtet, das ist Sochi. Das kann ich bei anderen Stadionen halt nicht sagen. Das ist für mich nur so ein Kriterium, wo ich sage, okay, das Stadion hat was Besonderes.
Das war das Stadion, das so eine Muschelform im Entfernen hat.
Genau, so geöffnet ist es an den Seiten, wo sie aber auch so kleine mobile Tribünen noch reingestellt haben, wo sich dann Leute auch im Regen saßen, als es ein bisschen getröpfelt hat. Aber leider nichts topt je Katharinenburg, weil es hat wirklich was Spezielles.
Man wird schon ein bisschen neidisch auf euch, wenn man mit euch über eure vier Wochen Russland spricht. Das muss man schon mal sagen. Hendrik, was war denn so die netteste Reisebegebenheit, die du so hattest? Wir haben jetzt schon über Nachtzüge gesprochen, die im Schritttempo gefahren sind. Sicherlich bist du auch das eine oder andere Mal geflogen. Gab es da irgendwas, wo du denkst, okay, das wird wahrscheinlich für mich persönlich von dieser WM noch bleiben?
Da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen nachdenken. Also die Flüge liefen alle sehr reibungslos und unspektakulär. Ich weiß nicht, ob das als Reisebegebenheit zählt, weil eigentlich sind ja Taxi-Geschichten immer so, jeder erzählt Taxi-Geschichten, aber ich fand das Taxifahren in Russland war immer ein absolutes Spektakel, weil die Leute wahnsinnig schnell unterwegs sind, weil die in den Taxen dann auch immer irgendwie, denen war das halt egal, ob da jetzt Fahrgäste drin saßen, die haben trotzdem immer so Krawall-Techno gehört, die dann auch immer auf volle Lautstärke und dann halt irgendwie so über diese, irgendwie nachts um drei über diese breiten russischen Straßen, das hat ja schon was, das war schon irgendwie, das sind so Erlebnisse und die Leute waren total nett und haben auch versucht, in Gespräche zu verwickeln, auch wenn ihr gemerkt habt, man spricht kein Russisch, dann hat man sich halt irgendwie über Google Translate in Gespräche verwickelt, also das sind so, da fällt es mir jetzt schwer, diese eine Begebenheit rauszusuchen, aber diese Taxifahrten während dieser WM, WM, das sind schon Sachen, die bleiben oder wie hängen.
Nils, hast du da irgendwas erlebt?
Ja, also ich hab auch gar nicht groß erzählt, aber ich fand die Zugfahrten sehr toll. Ich muss sagen, ich hab mich auf die Zugfahrten immer gefreut, weil da lernt man auch die Leute kennen. Und nach so einem, meine Trips waren gar nicht so lange, weil sonst hätt ich's gar nicht geschafft mit den verschiedenen Stadien. Aber also maximal so 13, 14 Stunden Fahrten mit drinne. Und auch natürlich über Nacht. Aber ich hab Journalisten kennengelernt, mit denen ich dann aus Finnland die einfach gequatscht habe oder... Ich hab auch ganze Familien, russische Familien kennengelernt, die so stolz waren, dass sie ein Ticket für ein Spiel bekommen haben und dann zusammen hingefahren sind und das...
Und dann ist einer von denen in Stadion gegangen?
Nee, alle zusammen haben alle Tickets bekommen. Nee, das sind sie nicht. Aber auch, dann haben sich alle Trikots gekauft und zwar manchmal auch der Vater von dem einen Land, der Sohn von dem anderen Land. Dann konnte der Vater nicht Englisch, der Sohn hat es übersetzt, wenn er Englisch konnte. Und die waren sehr gastfreundlich, wollten alles mit dir teilen. Haben dir dann geholfen, wenn das im Zug unklar war. Das ist sehr angenehm und so stelle ich mir das auch vor. Und so fand ich das Reisen auch immer sehr angenehm. Also das bleibt im Kopf hängen. Genauso habe ich, glaube ich, auf einer Fahrt, da war ich beim Deutschland-Spiel und habe mich gleich weitergefahren zum Schwedenspiel, auch nach Nischi Novkrotn im Zug. Und habe dann Schweden kennengelernt im Zug. Und Skandinavier-Zufe sind immer sehr gut, die sprechen so gut Englisch und die haben so viel zu erzählen. Das war einfach eine angenehme Fahrt, mit denen über Gott und die Welt zu reden. Da habe ich über den letzten Turnier geredet, der war auch, hat er erzählt und so weiter. Allgemein ist, wenn man bei der WM reist, bei so einem Turnier und macht das mal dann so wie ich und geht es alleine an. Man ist nie alleine, man lernt so viele Leute kennen. Also ich habe in Hostels übernachtet, da habe ich die ganze Nacht durchgequatscht mit Jugendlichen aus allen möglichen Ländern, nicht nur von WM-Ländern, sondern auch aus Singapur, die einfach hingekommen sind und die WM sehen wollten. Und da lernt man, das ist das, was das Tolle an so einem Turnier hat. Also das vielleicht ein bisschen untergeht und vielleicht auch ein bisschen idealistisch oder so. Aber das finde ich sogar ein bisschen Völkerverständigung da, wo alle Spaß haben wollen und dann, selbst wenn sie nur ins Ferienfest gehen und ein bisschen trinken wollen oder was auch immer, man lernt sehr viele Leute kennen und die einfach nur Spaß haben wollen im Fußball. Und das ist schon sehr angenehm. Und die Sprachbarrieren, in Englisch gibt es die eigentlich nicht. Und beim Russen kann man die auch immer irgendwie umgehen. Und deswegen bleibt sowas immer hängen. Ganz viele Gespräche mit ganz vielen Leuten.
Ich muss sagen, das hört sich wirklich sehr gut an. Und hört sich so an, dass jenseits von all dem Commerz und all dem, was die FIFA da tut, um auch die Gastgeberländer zu gängeln und noch den letzten Euro rauszupressen, dann doch viel von dem noch bestehen bleibt, was eben einfach so Turniere auszeichnet. Dass man sich einfach mit Menschen aus ganz, ganz vielen Ländern trifft und ganz interessante Erfahrungen macht und einfach viel Neues entdeckt und das alles in einer schönen Atmosphäre, wo man alle das gemeinsame Interesse am Fußball teilt. Das hört sich schon wirklich eigentlich, hört sich wirklich gar nicht so weit weg von der Best World Cup Ever.
Wobei, dann kann man natürlich sagen, dann ist jeder World Cup der Best World Cup Ever, weil das ist ja einfach, das ist einfach das Wesen von so einer WM, dass man halt dort viele Leute aus der ganzen Welt auf einem vergleichbar kleinen Raum hat, die alle Bock auf Fußball haben und halt alle irgendwie gerade fremd dort sind, wo sie sind. Von daher ist das natürlich nicht Russland-spezifisch, aber ich habe das genauso empfunden. Also noch nie in so kurzen Zeitraum so viele Leute aus so vielen verschiedenen Ländern getroffen oder kennengelernt. Das macht dann schon auch, neben der ganzen Arbeit, macht es dann das doch extrem angenehm.
Gab es denn auch Vorurteile, die ihr jetzt nicht mehr habt und die ihr jetzt stellvertretend auch bei allen Hörern und Hörern aufbrechen könnt über Russland, über die russischen Menschen?
Also ich gehe immer davon aus, dass ich eben vor sechs Jahren in Polen in der Ukraine war und als die Auslösung war und hieß das Deutschland in der Ukraine spielt, ich habe gesagt, hm, ich habe keine Polen gesehen. Am Schluss war ich so froh, weil die Ukraine so toll war, weil die Leute toll fand und das Land. Deswegen war für mich auch klar, zu komplett verschiedenen kann Russland nicht sein. Deswegen wurde ich auch nicht enttäuscht. Und ich fand es auch toll, in Landzeiten, wo du siehst, die Leute sprechen eine andere Sprache, es ist eine andere Schrift, die kleiden sich anders, essen andere Sachen. Das macht es erst interessant, in Land zu reisen. Deswegen wurde ich auch jetzt nicht enttäuscht oder in eine andere Richtung. Mir ist nicht absolut klar, dass zum Beispiel, wenn ich mit Polizisten geredet habe, dass die anders auf mich reagieren als auf einen Einheimischen. Das wurde mir auch bestätigt und es ist auch so gewesen. Ich kann eine Geschichte erzählen, immer witzig, im Stadion haben sie mich darauf hingewiesen, dass ich doch bitte beim deutschen Spiel, als ich in der Sonne stand, mein Trikot wieder anziehen sollte. Und dann habe ich gesagt, warum denn? Dann habe ich gesagt, eine FIFA-Regel. Dann habe ich gesagt, nee, das sehe ich nicht ein. Dann sind noch dreimal kommende Voluntärer. Und irgendwann hat sie aufgeben, weil sie mir nichts sagen konnte. Ich glaube, wenn du sonst im Spiel bist und bei dem russischen Liga und dir dann irgendetwas, was du machen sollst oder nicht, und du legst dich dann mit dem an, dann tust du es besser ein. Dann macht man es auch nicht. Da haben auch Leute bestätigt, ich habe einmal einem Polizisten genau beim Eingang widersprochen, das fand er nicht so witzig. Da habe ich gefragt, warum das so ist. Und er sagt, wir wissen es ja nicht. Er hat es mir eindeutig zu verstehen gegeben. Ich will es gar nicht schlecht machen. Es geht nur, da habe ich mir gemerkt, okay, wir Fans, uns ging es da auch sehr gut, muss man sagen. Und das darf man nie vergessen. Also, ich meine, wir durften die U-Bahn umsonst benutzen. Wir, die Touristen, die das Geld haben, die Fans, die Einheimischen mussten für die U-Bahn-Tasse zahlen und haben weniger Geld. Also nur als Beispiel. Also, uns wurde schon sehr viel für uns gemacht. Ich gehe jetzt nicht direkt auf deine Frage ein, aber das ist bei mir so hängen geblieben eben. Und ansonsten, es gibt für mich keinen Grund jetzt, wenn man durch die Probleme, die man dir ausblendet, nicht nach Russland zu reisen, ein schönes Land, es gibt eine andere Kultur zu entdecken, was auch immer. Man muss ja mit sich vereinbaren, wenn man sagt, okay, ich will da nicht hinreisen, weil ich nicht den Herr Putin unterstützen will oder andere, aber dann dürfte man viele andere Länder auch nicht reisen, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Ja, du, ich lebe in Bayern also.
Ich sag's da auch in der Antlas-Ausfang. Genau, ja.
Ja, aber ich... Ey, du bist bald nicht mal mehr EU-Hendrik, also...
Ich würde mich da eigentlich genauso anschließen, dass natürlich, wenn man als Fan oder als Journalist dort unterwegs ist, ist man in einer privilegierten Stellung, weil man Sachen darf, wie der einheimische Russe, wenn nicht gerade die Menschen in Russland leben, wenn nicht gerade WM ist, nicht dürfen. Ich glaube, das, Max, hattest du in der Folge mit der Katrin Scheidt mal besprochen, als es zum Beispiel darum ging, was das Alkoholtrinken auf der Straße angeht und solche Sachen. Oder, Nils, wie du sagst, wir dürfen halt mit der U-Bahn kostenlos fahren. Die Leute, die dort leben, müssen halt für die U-Bahn zahlen. Von daher sind wir natürlich in einer absolut privilegierten Lage und es war klar, dass Russland alles dafür tun wird, ein möglichst gutes, freundliches, offenes Bild abzugeben. Und das war diese WM natürlich schon –es ist natürlich politische WM –so. Aber das vorausgeschickt waren die Erlebnisse, die man an Vorort hatte, alle absolut positiv. Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich groß mit Vorurteilen nach Russland gereist bin, aber mit Herr schon in Form von so gemischten Gefühlen. Von wegen mal gucken, wie das alles würde. Die Leute waren ausnahmslos nett, sehr, sehr hilfsbereit. Wurde auch schon von vielen anderen Leuten geschildert, die dort waren. Das sieht man, dass die Leute in Russland einfach sehr, sehr hilfsbereit sind. Ich hatte eine Situation in der U-Bahn. Da stand ich und jemand saß und meinte, ob ich mich setzen möchte. Weil ich halt gepackter war, meinte ich, alles gut. Ich bin noch in einem Alter, ich kann auch in der U-Bahn stehen. Ich meinte, wirklich, setz dich. Ich meinte, alles gut, wirklich. Dann bin ich stehen geblieben und dann ist eine Station weiter, eine Frau eingestiegen. Sie fragte dann auch, möchtest du dich setzen? Sie meinte auch, alles gut. Dann hat sie auf den Platz gesetzt, dass sie jetzt bitte sitzt. Ich hatte schon das Gefühl, dass diese Hilfsbereitschaft eine große Sache in Russland ist. Das bleibt auf jeden Fall hängen. Ansonsten sind die Städte spannend, die Architektur ist spannend, die Kultur ist spannend. Deswegen würde ich einfach sagen, wer da Lust hat, der sollte einfach mal nach Russland reisen und sich das angucken. Das hat der Kollege Paul Linke bei Twitter geschrieben. Dass es einfach immer hilft, um sich vielleicht ein etwas vollständiges Bild zu bilden, sodass negiert nicht die Probleme, die es gibt, aber es trägt einfach zu einem vollständigen Bild bei.
Über was wollen die Leute mit einem reden, wenn es mal nicht um Fußball geht? Klar, das wird das erste Thema sein. Aber interessiert die dann auch irgendwas Besonderes? Interessieren die sich für Politik oder wollen die wissen, wie ihr in den Ländern, in denen ihr gerade lebt, unterwegs seid? Nils, was waren so die Gespräche, die du geführt hast?
Also leider haben sich gar nicht so viele Gespräche ergeben. Prinzipiell ist es immer so, dass die Leute wissen wollen, wie einem Russland gefällt. Und da rede ich auch gerne drüber und sage auch, mir gefällt auch in Russland auch, dass es zum Beispiel nicht ganz so perfekt und sauber ist wie in Deutschland. Ich mag das lieber. Deswegen kenne ich auch gerne andere Länder, wo ich sage, es muss nicht um die Europaseite. Sage ich den Leuten auch, erkläre es denen, dann wundern sie sich drüber, weil sie finden das toll. Ich sage mir aber auch, zum Beispiel gesagt, dass das halt wirklich sehr, wie auch vorhin schon Hendrik erklärt hat, in diesem Innenraumbereich bei der FIFA, in den Städten war das extrem gekleant und sauber. Die Obdachlosen wurden beiseitegeschafft. Es muss man einfach sagen, es ist passiert. Es war einfach sauber und perfekt, aber es war schon zu sauber. Das ist mir hängen geblieben. Ansonsten habe ich mal eben, vorhin schon angedeutet, durch diesen Walk durch Moskau irgendwann Zeit gehabt, mit diesem Russen zu reden, der mir das erklärt hat, und der auch gebildet war und der eher so ausgedrückt hat, dass er meinte, dass er nicht versteht, warum der Westen, dieses schlechte Bild von Moskau und von Russland hat, und warum man nicht verstehen könnte, warum die Krim so lau war, und warum man nicht verstehe, dass es in Richtung Ostukraine so läuft. Das war schon interessant. Ich hätte gerne mit ihm darüber geredet, ich kenne mich da auch einigermaßen aus, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, wenn ich ihm wirklich meine Meinung sage, dann hätte ich ihn sehr verletzt. Das wollte ich dann auch nicht machen. Er war gerade an der Gaskäbe und wollte uns sein Land zeigen und war stolz auf Moskau. Das habe ich auch gerne mitgenommen. Daran wollte ich ihn wirklich nicht verletzen. Und ich glaube, das hätte ich schon getan, wenn ich gesagt hätte, das kann man aus zwei verschiedenen Perspektiven sehen. Ich habe es mal so formuliert im Tweet. Das Land ist halt riesig und so groß wie das Land ist, sind auch teilweise die Komplexe und der Stolz. Ich finde es ein ganz tolles Land. Die Flüsse sind riesig, die Gebäude, die Städte und der Stolz auch. Es kann auch viel Stolz sein, aber auch teilweise die Komplexe, die sie haben. Und das hat man schon auch gemerkt, wenn ich mit den Leuten länger mal unterhalten habe. Es war nicht oft der Fall, aber das hast du schon gemerkt. Und dann merkst du schon, dass das nicht alles in Ordnung ist zwischen Russland und vor allem Europa und so weiter. Das ist mir so hängen geblieben, wenn ich mit den Leuten darüber gesprochen habe.
Ja, das kann ich im Grunde nur so bestätigen. Max, du meintest ja, über was man gesprochen hat, wenn man nicht über Fußball gesprochen hat. Vielleicht muss man trotzdem noch einmal sagen, wenn man gesagt hat, man kommt aus Deutschland, dann war natürlich gleich, ach Deutschland, was war denn da los und woran hat es gelegen?
Schade, ist ja unglaublich und dann habt ihr gesagt, die haben nicht die Hunde mitgesungen, dann haben sie gesagt, ach so, ja klar, haben wir uns auch schon gedacht.
Genau, und falscher Hashtag. Also kann man nie so um Fußball ganz drum rum, aber ansonsten war das auch mein Eindruck, dass die Leute oftmals ein sehr wenig differenziertes Bild von gewissen Dingen haben. Und wenn man ihnen dann sagt, Nils, wie du meinst, das sehe ich immer komplett anders, aber das kann man doch auch anders sehen, dass sie das halt eben nicht sehen. Und dass man die Leute dann wahrscheinlich eher verletzt und dass man dann, ich weiß nicht, ob man da vielleicht auch eher konfrontativer sein müssen, aber dass man dann auch aus solchen Gesprächen sich dann eher zurückzieht und man dann eher sagt, okay, dann, aber Russland ist schön und die Städte sind toll. Hat man halt immer so was gesprochen. Und mal ganz ehrlich, das waren bei mir tatsächlich auch so die meisten Gespräche. Also es ging da selten richtig tief, sondern es war wirklich oft, was war es mit den Deutschen und wie gefällt es dir hier? Und da konnte ich dann jeweils sagen, gefällt es dir gut, aber bei den Deutschen habe ich den Rasenfunk empfohlen.
Na gut, das wird denen sehr geholfen haben. Aber finde ich natürlich trotzdem gut, vor allem bei so langen Zugreisen. Da habe ich vorhin schon gedacht, als du gesagt hast, 15 Stunden Zugreise, habe ich mir gedacht, geil, das ist ja fast der Rasenfunk-Royal.
Ja, aber ohne Telefonsignal natürlich.
Ach, gibt es ein Land, das noch schlechteres Netz hat als Deutschland?
Nein. Also in diesen Zügen war es tatsächlich so, wenn du nicht gerade irgendwo stehst oder in eine größere Stadt fährst, dann hatte ich das oft, dass ich tatsächlich keinen Signal hatte. Man war dann wirklich mal so 10 Stunden. Da muss man ja reden. Man war da wirklich schlafen. Aber man war dann wirklich so 10 Stunden mal in so einem Kommunikationsloch.
Das kenne ich nicht anders. Aber ich habe es auch geschätzt, weil ich tendenziell wahrscheinlich jetzt so oft am Handy bin und habe nicht gestört. Man konnte die tolle Landschaft angucken oder man konnte wie gesagt schlafen, wenn man es konnte wegen der Hitze. Oder auch mit Leuten reden. Also hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile. Ich fand es gar nicht so schlimm.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Also das war auch komplett wertneutral gemeint. Ich fand es auch okay, mal so ein bisschen einfach mit Leuten zu sprechen oder Musik zu hören oder eben nicht ständig irgendwie.
Ja, wäre eigentlich ganz gut für meinen Urlaub. Vielleicht fahre ich nach Russland. Ich hänge auch zu viel am Handy. Da kommen auch zu viele Notifications immer rein. Na ja, das sind First-Word-Problems, wie sie First-Wordiger nicht sein könnten. Ich finde eigentlich, dass wir ganz gut so einen Eindruck davon bekommen haben, was ihr vor Ort erlebt habt. Tolle Reisen, die ihr da hattet. Der eine beruflich, der andere privat. Und doch irgendwie sich ähnlich. Und in einem faszinierenden Land, das wir ja auch schon durch die ganze Sendung mit Kathrin Scheib gehört haben, mit der ich morgen auch noch mal einen Kurzpass aufnehmen werde. Das heißt, von der kriegen wir auch noch mal so einen Moskauer Blick auf, wie war jetzt diese WM insgesamt. Und dann haben wir, glaube ich, ein ganz rundes Paket geschnürt hier im Rasenfunk. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was ihr loswerden wollt? Rückblickend jetzt auf dieses Fußballturnier? Oder habt ihr alle Dinge erzählt, die euch auf dem Herzen lagen?
Nee, ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind durch alles irgendwie ganz gut durch und haben, glaube ich, so alles irgendwie angesprochen, was man da irgendwie zu sagen kann. Also natürlich ist jetzt die große Frage, was heißt das für dieses Land? Aber wenn es tatsächlich rumgeht, was hat man so erlebt? Ich glaube, irgendwie haben wir viel besprochen. Und ich fand das Nils Arnold aber total spannend, diese Fansicht zu sehen von jemandem, der als Fan so mal die WM unterwegs war.
Es ist vor allem interessant zu sehen, wenn wir drauf gehen, was in vier Jahren sein könnte, was dann los ist. Das wäre jetzt mal eine Abschlussfrage gewesen. Ja, Entschuldigung, das war nicht. Also was ich sagen würde, erstens, der Appell reißt, guckt es euch an, es ist immer lohnenswert, es hat sich in anderer Sicht, hat auch Hendrik ganz toll gesagt, das ist genau der Punkt, einen eigenen Eindruck zu verschaffen. Und zweitens, aus Fußballfansicht oder Traditionssicht weiß ich, wenn ich da hinreisen sollte, in vier Jahren, was da stattfinden wird. Eins ist für den Crown-Topper ein Paradies, weil er jeden Tag drei Spiele sehen kann, das letzte in Herz hüpft. Die Frage ist, was mache ich nach vier Tagen, weil ich alle Stadion durchhalbe und es gibt keinen Alkohol und es gibt keine Kultur, also nicht mich bösgemal übertrieben formuliert, was mache ich dann? Dann werden sich viele Fans noch an Russland zurückerinnern und denken, dass es ein Paradies war, das alles da zu entdecken gab. Ich will es nicht so schlecht machen, aber vielleicht werde ich auch ganz überrascht sein, wer weiß, keine Ahnung. Aber Russland ist immer eine Reise wert.
Aber du wirst auf jeden Fall wieder auch Katar mitnehmen?
Ich sage es für jeden Turnier, ich mache es nicht und dann mache ich es doch. Alle lachen über mich und glauben mir sowieso nicht mehr. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ich mir da keine vier Wochen sein werde. Wenn Hendrik da arbeiten muss, hat er wahrscheinlich kurze Wege. Das wird toll für ihn sein. Die Frage ist, ob er jeden Abend gleich Tage an einer Hotelbar sich einen Abendtrink genehmigen möchte, der immer gleich ist. Das weiß ich nicht. Es gibt was zu sehen, auf jeden Fall. Ich fahre viel mal nach Oman rüber und sonst was. Es gibt viel zu sehen, aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, da war dann Russland wahrscheinlich noch das Paradies dagegen.
Genau, das sind ja noch viereinhalb Jahre Zeit, sich das zu überlegen, ob man das dann macht. Aber ich finde auch, das haben mir noch andere Kollegen gesagt oder geschrieben, dass Russland vielleicht schon die letzte WM war, wie man sie kannte, also in dem ganzen Land und auch im Sommer. Und es wird in der Katar natürlich alleine schon wegen dieser beiden Aspekte. Nicht sagen, dass es nicht noch andere, aber wegen dieser beiden Aspekte wird es eine ganz andere WM.
Ja, mal gucken. Dann wird natürlich die Nordamerika, Mittelamerika-WM noch kommen. Wenn ihr mich fragt, kommt dann China. Das könnte natürlich dann wieder interessant werden, wenn man da dann auch die Möglichkeit hat, viel zu sehen. Aber zwischendrin haben wir... Genau, über die wollte ich gerade noch sprechen. Also wenn man jetzt eure Geschichten hört, was ihr so erlebt habt und was ihr von diesem Land zu erzählen habt, finde ich es irgendwie noch dramatischer, dass es jetzt diese aufgebrochene Euro gibt. Es kann auch sein, dass es besser ist, dass man vielleicht noch mehr sieht. Aber vom Gefühl her, in meinem Kopf ist es noch nicht so ganz rein, dass das eine EM ist, die über ganz Europa verteilt ist. Und so schön das Signal sein mag. Aber ich glaube, irgendetwas wird fehlen.
Ich ringe da auch noch mit mir, ob ich das jetzt, wie ich das finden soll. Ich finde, das widerspricht natürlich ganz krass so einem Turniercharakter, wie man das kennt, dass die Turniere, dass das Turnier in einem Land ist, dass man dadurch immer so auch über die, ob am Fernsehen oder vor Ort so ein bisschen was mitbekommt über Land und Leute. Und das fällt natürlich da komplett weg. Andererseits kann man natürlich auch sagen, ob du jetzt in Russland 15 Stunden im Zug fährst, oder ob du mit Billigflieger irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, 3 Stunden von München nach Bucharest fliegst, macht da wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht mehr so den großen Unterschied. Ich ringe da auch noch so ein bisschen mit mir, wie ich das finden soll.
Da habe ich eigentlich Geiz hinzuzufügen. Ich glaube, da wird nicht diese Turnierstimmung aufkommen, wie es wird. Ich finde, es wird es nicht komplett verteufeln. Es soll nur einmalige Sache sein. Vor allem ist es auch interessant für Länder, wo niemals eine EM bekommen wird. Ob es jetzt gleich Aserbaidschan ist oder sowas, die kriegen ein Spiel, das finde ich schon mal toll. Aber dieses Flair wird komplett flöten gehen, weil wenn ein Spiel in Deutschland ist, dann ist ja nicht in ganz Deutschland EM-Stimmung, glaube ich. Also nichts, wenn man es vergleicht, zum Beispiel mit der WM 2006. Und das ist schon schade, würde ich schon sagen. Aber auch da vielleicht läuft es ja ganz anders. Ich bin da ja kein Prophet, ich weiß es nicht.
Genau. Ich meine, du wirst da eh nicht hingehen. Dann sprechen wir nach der EM dann, wie es dann war. Ach ja, als du jetzt Aserbaidschan gesagt hast, da hätte ich jetzt fast schon wieder ein Fass aufgemacht. Das ist ja sportpolitisch und unpolitisch an sich auch nochmal ein ganz eigenes Ding. Aber das wollen wir jetzt nicht berühren. Es gab auch genügend negativ Berichterstattung, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, hier im Rasenfunk. Ich habe auch viel hinter die Kulissen von FIFA und ähnlichen Konstrukten geguckt. Jetzt haben wir mal so ein bisschen das, was Gianni Infantino im Intro gesagt hat, mit euren Erfahrungen abgedeckt. Und ich muss sagen, es war hochspannend, euch zuzuhören. Und ich bin ein bisschen neidisch über die Erfahrung, die ihr sammeln konntet. Meine WM-Erfahrung deckt sich mit dem, was ich jetzt gerade hier erlebe. Ich stehe an meinem Schreibtest und vor mir läuft das Aufnahmeprogramm. Das war meine WM. Meine WM-Erinnerung. Die längste Reise, die ich unternommen habe, war von hier einen Stockwerk runter ins Schlafzimmer. Und dann bin ich dort ins Bett gefallen. Ist auch was Besonderes. Naja, nein, nein, nein, ich wollte mich nicht beschweren. Es ist ja schön, dass man für Fußballgucken dann irgendwie auch noch Geld verdienen kann damit. Und ja, das zum Beruf machen kann, brauche ich dir, Hendrik, ja auch nicht zu erzählen. Das ist ja... We are living the dream.
Es ist natürlich... Ich will es natürlich in keiner Form irgendwie klein machen, weil bei so einer WM unterwegs zu sein und so eine Reise mitzuerleben und bei einer WM-Finale zu sitzen, das ist natürlich großartig. Aber andererseits ist es natürlich auch Arbeit. Und natürlich auch in einer gewissen Form anstrengend. Von daher, wie gesagt, ohne das kleinreden zu wollen. Aber es ist auch total okay, dass die WM vorbei ist. Ich freue mich, dann wieder nach Hause zu kommen. Aber diese Erfahrung, das war absolut grundreifig.
Nee, das stimmt. Aber das kommt auch, glaube ich, nicht weinerlich rüber. Das versteht auch, glaube ich, jede Hörerin und jeder Hörer. Wenn man sagt, also nach vier Wochen arbeiten rund in diesem Umfeld, reicht es dann auch allein heute, dieses Gefühl zu haben, dass kein Spiel mehr ist. Das war irgendwie... Also mich hat es wirklich ein bisschen befreit, wo sie sagt. Ich bin gedacht, ach cool, heute kann ich um 20 Uhr meine Sendung aufnehmen und muss nicht irgendwas gucken. Wie praktisch ist das denn? Naja, ich danke euch beiden sehr. Das war wirklich sehr, sehr spannend. Vielen, vielen Dank an Nils Arnold et Grummelgroh auf Twitter. Ich hoffe, du kriegst jetzt jede Menge Follower. Du postest immer ganz schöne Bilder. Man kann da einiges erleben. Vielen, vielen Dank, Nils, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen, vielen Dank auch an euch. War sehr auch interessant, die Position von Hendrik zu hören. Und auch voll interessant, dass sie sich schon zum großen Teil gedeckt hat. Das fand ich schon sehr interessant. Ja, hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank.
Das freut mich. Und vielen Dank an Hendrik Buchheister, freier Sportsportanalyst als et ha- Buchheister auf Twitter. Hendrik, danke dir und dann einen guten Rückflug zurück in den Urlaub. Nee, nicht zurück in den Urlaub. Also ich wollte erst sagen zurück nach Hause, aber du hast noch Zeit, dass du weiter in den Urlaub fliegst. Also genieße dann auch die freien Tage. Ach wunderbar, dann fanden wir das alle interessant. Ich hoffe, ihr auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für euer Interesse. Das war es jetzt fast mit der WM-Berichterstattung im Rasenfunk. Morgen wird noch ein letzter WM-Kurzpass erscheinen und dann ist die WM auch hier im Rasenfunk offiziell vorbei und damit dann auch eigentlich erst so wirklich die WM vorbei. Im Grunde läuft sie gerade noch. Das wissen bloß viele nicht. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. rasenfunk.de unterstützen ist die Zauberurl. Bis bald mal wieder. Macht's gut, tschau. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.